So what you're saying is before I report, I should disclose and then report the same day.
Or no, the next day.
Sorry, so it's one day.
Sure, if you want to time it so that you get your own CVE, the CVE gets public,
then you publish your own POC and you exploit it before everybody else.
I mean, yeah, I guess that's a public exploit.
It's going to be a busy couple of days.
I just saw you get like prepped.
You're like, at the countdown started, you backed up.
You like hyped yourself up.
Get a little stretch.
Get a little litty.
Dude, I'm getting myself ready for this one because this is going to be a feisty one today.
I'm going to have to bring the feist to the show.
Oh, boy.
All right.
Because we are representing.
We got in the left corner, we have Justin Gardner representing the hackers on the right corner.
We have Joe Margulis representing the hackers and the program managers.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm playing devil's advocate here.
No, it should be a fun one, man.
I'm excited.
And yeah, I'm going to, you know, we're pretty tight.
I, you know, and so I just, it's going to feel good to like, just kind of rip you a new one in this debate, I think, you know?
Okay.
I mean, listen, I was looking through this doc and there was a lot of very feistily written points and I had some very feistily written answers in my head.
So that's great.
In true Joel fashion, you've got the feistily written stuff in your head.
That's good.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's take a little breath.
Take a little breather.
Calm down.
We got a news segment to hit before we get into the meat.
All right.
So first up on the news.
Well, first of all, we're kind of a little bit, a little bit light on news this week.
I don't know if that's just because everyone like dumped all their stuff at, oh, DEF CON.
Yeah, I was going to, I actually haven't even asked you about DEF CON.
How was DEF CON?
Yeah.
I mean, DEF CON was pretty good.
I got COVID.
So that was the less good side of it.
But yeah, other than that, it was good.
It was fun.
It was great to see everybody.
Good to hang out with people who sometimes I don't even get to see people like once a year.
So yeah, it's always a nice time.
Did you even, did you go to DEF CON itself or just H1702?
I didn't even step foot in the convention center.
I didn't buy a badge.
But like, honestly, it doesn't seem like I miss out on much given what the badges were this year.
But yeah, no, my personal opinion is that most of the time the talks are all uploaded, except for I think a couple of the villages sometimes don't do it.
There's like a whole thing with that.
But for the most part, pretty much every single talk is uploaded on YouTube.
So if there's stuff that I didn't get to see, I can just go see it.
Oftentimes, the really good talks, I'll just hear what they are and I'll go look them up.
And like I said, all the people that I tend to see, I end up seeing outside of DEF CON.
I really like going to DEF CON to see the talks.
But like one of the disadvantages is that you can't see everything.
So, you know, I figured I'd save my money, enjoy Vegas a little bit, a little more chill, a little bit less walking around.
Save your money and then enjoy Vegas.
Sure.
Save my money, buy, get off.
Go to the tables or whatever.
Did you gamble at all?
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
We're not, from the tone of that, yeah, I say we're not going to go down that path.
Yeah, I didn't walk away a mega millionaire.
I'll tell you that.
Didn't walk away with a job.
All right.
Well, that's part of the experience, I suppose.
Yeah.
And about the talks, you know, yeah, I kind of agree.
I think there's something cool about being able to go in person, especially if it's your friends, you know, and support them and, you know, ask questions afterwards if you have questions.
But yeah, most of the time on those talks, you're going to want to rewind and like take notes and like, you know, dive a little bit deeper.
So it's nice that they put them up on, you know, YouTube a little bit later.
Yeah.
Actually, they're already up on the DEF CON YouTube.
Yeah, they are.
Yeah.
It's only been a couple of weeks.
So if you want to go check out those talks, they're all available.
Yeah.
It's been it's been a long couple of weeks, man.
You know, I realized we haven't actually had a Justin and Joel episode since then.
So, yeah, that's.
Yeah.
First you had COVID, then I had COVID.
I got a COVID on a cruise.
That was that was rough.
Let's see here.
All right.
Well, let's let's let's hit the news then.
Um, first item up on the list.
I'll talk about was was Rezo, a loyal, a loyal follower of the podcast.
Bless his heart.
True.
Um, released something really cool called prompt injection primer for engineers.
And essentially it's a it's a document outlining what kind of things you need to be worried
about as an engineer from with regards to prompt prompt injection.
And yeah, I know we have a lot of engineers listening to this to this pod.
So I wanted to shout it out.
And if any of you are working with, um, AI related, uh, tools and are are kind of a little
bit worried about what prompt injection may as it is an unresolved bug, we still don't
have a solution to prompt injection.
That's perfect.
You know, it's not like just escaping our, you know, uh, double quotes and single quotes
in SQL and stuff like that.
It's it's unsolved problem.
Um, I think Joseph does a good job here of, um, breaking down what exactly the, the attack
vector is.
He's got a little flow chart on whether you need to be worried about it or not.
So I think this can make it a lot easier for people to understand what kind of impact this
bug could have.
Yeah.
It's super interesting.
Um, I saw that he had posted on Twitter and it seems like a great resource to just sort
of like put some stuff out in, in this space of security.
Uh, it's such a new technology and there's so many things that we haven't really figured
out.
Like you said, it's, it's like an unresolved problem.
So I think it's great to have some awesome minds like Rezo and I think yourself as well,
right?
Um, you know, I may have seen it, you know, before it was released, you know?
Yeah.
So it's good to have these, these types of minds, uh, already working on the problem,
already putting out resources out there, helping companies get secure before they even know
it.
So yeah, yeah, for sure.
Um, so definitely check that out.
If you're, if you're working with AI stuff at all, pass it around to anybody who is working
with AI, because we all kind of saw what happened with web three when everyone went crazy boom
with web three stuff, you know, everyone was developing.
It was happening so fast.
Volums were flying all over the place.
Money was flying out of wallets left and right.
And so, um, luckily AI is not directly linked to currency like, like, uh, like web three
was, but, um, not yet.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
Not, not yet.
Uh, so we, hopefully we won't have quite as severe of a fallout, but, um, definitely something
to check out if you're working with it.
Yeah.
Um, totally.
All right.
Did you, uh, did you see this thing from Portswigger?
Uh, yeah.
It's another access vector.
Freaking love when a Portswigger research dropped something.
So they dropped a, um, I guess Chrome now supports the on scroll end sort of event handler.
Um, so this is a great way to get past those pesky laughs for, I don't know, hopefully a
month or two, uh, until they update their word list or whatever, but, um, it works on
any element.
So in the, in the little tweet that we'll link in the description, they have it working on
the XSS element, right?
The little fake XSS element.
And if you combine this with the auto scroll to a specific element feature that they have
in, in Chrome, if you put like the ID and the hashtag in the hash fragment, uh, up at
the URL, then you can just pop it without any interaction.
Nice.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
This is one of those accounts.
Um, you mentioned this way early in the pod and I followed suit right after you did,
but I have tweet notifications turned off reports for research because it's just one of
those accounts that is constantly pumping out really like immediately useful information,
just like this, which is, you know, a screenshot and a link to their, their post about this
specific vector and how you can use it.
You know, it doesn't get much better than that.
So, uh, yeah, yeah, this is a super, super interesting, especially if XSS is are your bread
and butter on scroll.
There you go.
Yeah.
So XSS that's, that's, that's that for XSS.
The next thing that I wanted to talk about was, uh, this talk that Gunner Andrews, AKA
Golden Infosec did at Recon Village.
I saw this pop up on YouTube and I know that he's been working.
What the heck?
My Google home just started freaking out in front of me.
Stop.
Unplugged.
Um, uh, maybe Gunner Andrews, does it activate my Gunner?
What did you do?
Oh no.
Does it activate my Google home?
No.
Um, yeah, no, I know he does some crazy recon stuff with regards to, um, specifically with
regards to serverless architecture.
So I was really thrilled to see that Recon Village put up a talk by him.
Um, just like Joe was talking about in the beginning of the episode, you know, you don't
necessarily have to be at DEF CON to get all this wonderful information that they released.
And, uh, I watched through this talk and it's super awesome.
And not, not only does he come in, he's not like a serverless fan boy either.
Like he comes in and he says like, Hey, this is the, these are the pros and cons of serverless.
This is when you should use serverless.
This is when you should just use a server, you know?
Um, and, and, uh, so he does a really good job of outlining what kind of tasks, uh, work
best, uh, in, in serverless architecture, um, and how to use that to power your bug bounty
hunting and your recon.
Um, so definitely a hard recommend on that one.
Um, yeah, I'm gonna, I've got that on my list and I'm gonna have to watch it after we, we
finish recording.
Yeah.
It's got, I want to say, how long is it?
40 minutes.
Yeah.
It, I put it on, I put it on 2X and I was still getting the full, the full value out of
it.
Um, so definitely, definitely worth a listen.
Awesome.
All right.
Before we hop into the main content real quick, Jason Haddix, former guest of the show.
Um, Jay Haddix, Jason Haddix, whatever you want, you know him by.
Uh, he is doing a course.
It's the Bug Hunters, uh, methodology live training course.
And he has very generously given us a invite code to give away.
So one of our listeners, uh, will be randomly selected to get a free access to his live Bug
Hunters methodology.
$550 value.
Yeah.
I mean, huge value.
So first of all, major shout out to, to Jason.
Thank you.
We, uh, we can't appreciate it enough.
We're hoping that, uh, whichever viewer ends up winning this, uh, will get the most value
out of it as possible.
Give us your notes.
Yeah.
It's funny, actually.
Funny story.
So I had talked to Jason about this and Jason's like, yeah, you know, I can, I can probably
give you a code to give away on the pod, you know, something like that.
And so he messages me the link and then he's like, oh, I should probably just message Joel
the link as well.
So he just like drops the discount code in Joel's DMs.
Right.
And Joel's like, oh, heck yeah.
Like, I can't wait to go to this course.
Like, this is going to be awesome.
And I'm like, no, Joel, that's, that's for, that's for the listeners.
Okay.
Like, I saw it.
I was like, oh, I'm going to have to claim that later.
And then like a couple hours later, I was talking about it with Justin and he was like,
oh no, we're going to give that away.
I was like, okay, it looks like it's the same code.
And then like within a few minutes, I get a message from Jason.
He's like, by the way, that's, that's the giveaway on the podcast.
I was like, oh, okay.
You can see the disappointment in Joel's eyes.
Like, yeah.
So, so definitely you're going to want to enter to win this.
We have a very easy way to entry.
Just go to ctbb.show slash giveaway.
And that's, you'll be taken somewhere, probably Google form.
I haven't really figured it out yet, but somewhere.
On the new website, potentially.
Yeah.
On our new website.
So ctbb.show slash giveaway.
And that's how you can enter to win a free entry to Jason Haddix's Bug Hunter methodology course.
Yeah.
And I'm looking through this, this course, man.
And I was reading through the description and it says explicitly,
so I think this matches well with the, with the critical thinking audience.
Unlike other courses, tbhm live is not an A to Z or beginners oriented course.
And I'm looking through the syllabus and this is a lot of content that he's going to try to cover in two days.
So I imagine he'll be moving pretty quickly.
Looks like a very, a very interesting course.
So definitely check that out.
Um, and like I sort of vaguely mentioned just a second ago and totally forgot to announce at the beginning,
we have launched a new website for critical thinking.
It is live.
Um, it will have, it's going to be a little bit better organized than our, our past website.
So we've got each episodes popping up.
We've got the video, we've got the audio, whichever your preferred medium is.
We've also got transcripts, which is something a lot of you guys have been asking for, for a long time.
Um, those will be attached to each podcast release.
Um, I'm not sure that it'll be, it'll be on like the instant that the episode drops,
but hopefully within the first couple hours of episode dropping, we should have the transcript up there, um,
and ready for you guys to consume.
So, uh, there's also a contact form on the website that you can get in touch with us, uh, via.
So shoot any questions or concerns about that over there.
Awesome.
All right.
Should we, uh, should we kick off the main, the main, the main show?
I don't even, the main, the main attraction.
Let's see.
All right.
Richie, we're going to need you to, Richie's our editor.
Richie put in like some sort of, you know, dun, dun, dun, dun, or something like that.
Here's some epic start.
Okay.
Wait, real quick, real quick.
I do need to get some formalities out of it.
Okay.
I do currently work at a tech company.
I'm not even going to name them.
We're just going to keep it completely out of this.
Um, I do manage buggy mounting programs there.
However, everything that we're going to say today has nothing to do with my employer,
has nothing to do with my job.
It has nothing to do with my day to day.
Um, if anything remotely like sensitive or anything, we're going to cut it out.
So, um, yeah, I just want to clarify that like, this is based on my experience as a program
manager and a bug bounty hunter.
This is not reflective of my employer or my current work or anything like that.
Okay.
Nice.
Fully disclaimed.
Red tape out of the way.
Yeah.
There you go.
Very nice.
And you've, you've had, um, you know, you've managed other programs in the past before too.
Yeah.
And I'm happy to say that like I, you know, before my current role, I was at Uber.
I managed, I helped, well, I didn't manage it, but I helped manage it, uh, alongside the
main manager.
Uh, so yeah, I, I definitely have had my fingers in a lot of different programs from the program
side for a couple, many, many years now.
So.
All right.
Disclaimers all over.
Boxing, boxing gloves are on Joel.
Boxing gloves off.
On.
Let's go.
Wait, off.
What the heck?
Wait.
This man's going to like knuckle to the face.
Suit off.
Boxing gloves on.
So I'm going into my, my state.
I'm going into my hacker hacker representation state, dude.
What is up with the, what is up with the zero day policy, man?
Like if your scope is vulnerable and it's in scope, why am I not getting paid for this
awesome zero day that I found?
Okay.
So like for the record, I think a lot of things we will probably like semi agree on.
And I think some of this should really be like sort of to the other program managers.
If your program is, you know, this is sort of my take that I think.
I need you to devil's advocate a little bit though.
Okay.
So like, I know you're a hacker and I know you're a good program manager.
Right.
And so I realized, you know, we may agree on some things, but also I want to hear the
other side as well.
You know?
Yeah.
So, so I'll tell you sort of both aspects for a minute.
So like, why, why, why shouldn't you get paid?
I mean, there's, there's a couple of reasons.
I think the main reason is that there's nothing that can be done from the company side to fix
this.
And I think we've discussed this a little bit when we talked with Shubs about sort of how
to navigate that kind of communication when you're reporting a zero day vulnerability,
especially if it's something that you found to a company and whether or not they should
be paying it.
And a lot of it boils down to what is the company supposed to do?
Because for one, it's nothing that their engineers cause.
It's nothing that they accidentally added or knew was there.
Like this is just an artifact of the fact that they use a piece of software and that other
company made a mistake.
Well, okay.
Their engineers did do something here because they put it, they put a domain, you know,
presumably they put a domain pointing to this asset, you know, I don't know if it's a cloud
asset, you know, if it's a cloud asset, then they just pointed their domain at it.
But you guys made the decision just like you would use, you know, to use open source software
to run, work with this provider.
And that has inherently put your users at risk.
Sure.
Yeah.
And so that's where I like, I'll start to agree with you is that like, there are certainly
systemic steps that you can take from a company side to help stop these things.
And that generally involves like doing audits ahead of time with the company, discussing what
their current security team and current security practices look like.
How do they store data?
What are their password policies?
What is their internal security policy?
Like there's a lot of things that you can do as sort of checks and balances to try and
make sure that the company you're about to work with and whose software you're about to
use will not compromise you.
But at the end of the day, you like you didn't write the code.
You're you probably don't even have access to the source code.
And so depending on what it is, like there might not be much you can do.
And yes, they they the engineers probably did create a DNS.
Don't give me that shit, Joel.
But they didn't do anything wrong from a security from a secure development standpoint.
OK, there's nothing that the engineer could have done differently that would have stopped
them from being vulnerable.
It was completely outside of their control.
OK, that's sort of true.
That is true.
And I see that point.
But also, heck that.
And and and I need the bounty right now.
Yeah, sure.
So so like, again, I agree with you.
And I think this is sort of where like from a program management perspective, where I draw
the line is basically, is there impact?
Yes or no.
Pay for impact.
Right.
Yeah.
Like, yeah, it doesn't necessarily matter if it's your fault.
It matters whether or not something can happen because of that vulnerability.
Right.
Yeah.
And so at the end of the day, like you should be taking responsibility for the impact to
your business, to your users, to your customers, whatever it is that like if you're using a piece
of software that makes you vulnerable, you should pay for that to some extent.
Now, I think it's fair to not pay a full bounty because there's a limited amount of things
that you can do.
I also think that there needs to be some sort of like, you know, how do I fix this?
Conversation?
Yeah.
Oh, OK.
OK.
Sure.
But like, how do I fix this?
Right.
Like, OK, you're reporting a zero day to me.
Can I set up firewall rule up?
Can I?
Yeah.
I mean, wow, like, what do I do to fix it?
What do you want me, the company who uses this piece of software to do?
Because if the other company doesn't even know about it, the only thing that we can do is
say, hey, by the way, there's a vuln in your software.
You need to fix this.
OK, so I got the little, you know, hyperbolized hacker out of my system a little bit there
and the raging.
But I'm going to try to approach this from an intellectual perspective as a hacker here.
So my answer to that would be that, you know, sure, you guys don't have access to the source,
the vulnerable source code that's running on the target, right?
Assuming it's a closed source, you know, project or whatever.
And so how do you remediate that situation?
Totally fair question, I think.
And whenever I report these, I always try to include some sort of remediation step.
Maybe, you know, changing some configuration in the actual third-party app that, you know,
you can find in the settings.
But at the end of the day, you can just stick a WAF in front of it.
Or you can stay, I mean, how hard is it to, like, spin up an Nginx reverse proxy, right?
And, like, just block off a specific endpoint.
Significantly easier said than done.
What?
Are you serious?
Yes, because, okay, here's the thing.
In a perfect universe where every company is just, like, five engineers with an AWS box,
yeah, that works.
You could just, like, spin up a service and be done with it.
But in most modern tech companies, there's so much more process and procedure
and, like, trying to fit into the existing technologies.
And they might not even use Nginx.
Like, there's so many other layers that don't just make it that easy.
Where, yes, that would be a super easy solution if it worked.
But it's completely dependent on implementation and use case.
Okay.
But, like, almost every organization is using some sort of reverse proxy, right?
Like, you know, whether it be, you know, Apache, Nginx, Trafic, or however you pronounce that thing.
Yeah.
Or have a WAF, right?
Like, you know, and so just, I mean, I don't know.
Maybe this is my lack of enterprise experience coming into play.
But if I were on a security team and I got a report of this and, you know, there's an RCE on this box, you know,
that you can only access through a certain point, I would want to be, you know, spinning up a, you know,
AWS, you know, reverse proxy.
What are they?
I forget what they're called.
I mean, like, the thing is that, like, yeah, if it's that case, there's a few things that you can do, right?
If it's not something business critical, IP restricted, take it offline, put it behind a firewall, put it behind VPN.
Yeah.
Change the configuration.
There's usually, like, a handful of things that you can sort of generically do that will probably help.
If it's an actual zero day, you know, there's, like, very few things that the company can do outside of, like, preventative measures around, like, preventing requests from even hitting the box, right?
Yeah.
So there's not much you can fix.
I see that you also mentioned one days in here.
Honestly, my opinion is that if it's a one day, like, that's fair game.
If there's an exploit out there publicly, especially, and you have the software and it's publicly exposed, that is fair game.
So what you're saying is before I report, I should disclose and then report the same day.
Or no, the next day.
Sorry.
So it's one day.
Sure.
If you want to time it so that you get your own CVE, the CVE gets public, then you publish your own POC and you exploit it before everybody else.
I mean, yeah, I guess that's a public exploit.
It's going to be a busy couple days in that scenario.
Yeah.
No.
Okay.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
And I do agree.
If it's got a public CVE, you know, then, you know, even if you're aware of it, I always add that having to do less asset, you know, enumeration or checking of your assets to say, like, hey, yeah, this bug is vulnerable to this.
I think that adds value.
And so there's definitely some other areas where the bug bounty hunters add value with their reports.
And also, it's an easier sell to the people that need to fix it.
Say, okay, yeah, sure.
Somebody posted this paper that affects our blah, blah, blah.
But it's a different story when you can say, actually, a hacker shelled this box this morning and was in here and could have deleted the whole system.
You know, I feel like that's an easier sell to your bureaucratic organization or whatever.
Yeah.
Being able to update that stuff in a more efficient way.
And hand in hand with that, also knowing what vulnerabilities are in the pipeline that are affecting your software so that you can fix it ASAP.
Yeah.
No, that totally makes sense.
Mariah's texting me something.
Let me just send her this.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
And I think, yeah, I think that piece about patch management is very important, you know, and oftentimes people, I guess maybe I shouldn't say oftentimes, but I've seen several times when people have started bug bounty programs and they don't have a solid patch management platform out.
And I just can think of this one time with my automation where like every week I was getting this ping.
This is vulnerable.
And they didn't patch the CVE, this critical CVE that leaked AWS creds, right?
Yeah.
For over a year.
And I'm like, what are you doing?
So anyway, so all right, you know, now I got to get.
What are you doing?
We'll get to that shortly because.
Okay, we'll get to that.
I know that's in there.
That's not, that's not the next question.
The next question is.
Okay, so let's talk about a little bit about disclosure.
Okay.
I have done some research.
I've found a vulnerability.
I reported to you because I want to give you a heads up.
But I also want to be able to disclose this.
But I would also like to be paid for my research.
Why, why not?
Why, like, you know, a lot of programs add do not disclose policies.
What's up with that homeboy?
Yeah.
Okay.
So, I mean, the reality is that a lot of this boils down to the fact that a lot of programs
have a legal and comms team.
Yeah.
Or both, a legal teams and a comms team.
And oftentimes, security vulnerabilities are viewed positively by the security community,
negatively by everybody else.
Right.
And so if you think about it, it's like.
Yeah, that's interesting.
The company doesn't really want to brag that they had a security vulnerability.
Right.
Sure.
The incentive there is good for the security team to be like, look, our bug bounty program
is working.
Great.
Terrible from a comms and publicity perspective around like, oh, customer data could have been
at risk or whatever.
Right.
Like, I think that is always the challenge.
And some companies are very good about owning security and being like, we don't give a shit.
We're going to be public about everything.
And like, if we have a security vulnerability, that's great.
We don't care.
We'd rather be public about it.
It doesn't really matter.
I think a lot of companies get really scared about that.
And rightfully so, because there's been plenty of outrage for various tech companies, Uber,
for example, around security vulnerabilities and how it was handled and how it was announced
or not announced and all that kind of stuff.
Can take the stock price and all that sort of thing.
Right.
And so, like, I think that is a real risk there.
Now, the other side is like, okay, I want to get paid.
Great.
Report it to the bug bounty program.
I want to disclose it.
Well, that's up to the program.
I see a lot of researchers who will report stuff and then get frustrated when they aren't
allowed to disclose or they, you know, disclose anyways or whatever.
Like, here's the reality of it.
When you submit a bug through a bug bounty program, you agree to the bug bounty program
terms and policy.
That states that you can't disclose stuff without the permission of the program.
If you disclose stuff without the permission of the program, you are violating the program
terms.
Yeah.
Which, number one, often excludes you from safe harbor protections.
And number two, sets you up for a platform ban or at least some sort of a suspension or
reprogression.
Right?
Yeah.
And so that's not to say that you can't report stuff without being able to disclose it.
You can always, like, email security at and, you know, reach out to them directly, not
going through the bug bounty program.
You're not agreeing to their program terms if you're not going through the bug bounty
program.
I wonder if you could submit directly to the bug bounty program, but still, but like explicitly
state in the report that I decline the terms and agreements to this.
And say, like, I, you know, I intend to disclose this bug, but I'm also giving you a heads up.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I mean, maybe.
I think that would be a little more nuanced because there's probably some stuff in the
hacker one terms of service that says, like, you know, whatever.
But it's definitely a way to set you up for platform problems for sure.
Yeah.
Like, here's, I just wouldn't recommend it.
And like, the other aspect of it is if you really want to want to disclose something and
the company really doesn't, you're going to set yourself up for a rocky relationship with
that company and that program every day after that.
Because if you decide to go ahead and disclose and they don't want to do it, they are really
not going to want to work with you in the future.
Right.
So if you find something like, you know, some other like really bad vuln and you want to
report it to them or you want to like, you know, get a bounty or something, how is that
company supposed to feel when they've got this researcher who's like been super aggressive
with them in the past about disclosures and now coming in with another vulnerability?
Yeah.
Like, are they going to fix it?
Yeah, probably.
It doesn't feel safe.
Are they going to want to like, you know, it really sets a bad precedent, I think, for
that type of, for the type of relationship that you want to have with the program,
which is like an amicable working relationship where you can.
Professional.
Yeah.
You can secure things together and both be like happy and positive about it, not be like,
I want to disclose this.
You can't disclose it.
Or I'm mad about that.
Like, you know, like at the end of the day, that's part of what, that's part of the bargain,
right?
Part of the bargain is that you get paid.
But that feels a little dirty, right?
Like that feels a little bit dirty if you say like, if you say it like that.
Because you said that's part of the bargain and it is part of the bargain and you're
totally right in representing it that way.
But essentially what you just said is we're paying you to keep your mouth shut, which is
like really sketchy and not the way that I really want to see bug bounties.
Yeah.
And I mean, like, I don't want to get too reductive here because I think that you could
frame a lot of things that way, but especially like any private program, you could phrase it
that way and that like, oh, you don't have a public program.
So like, why, you know, I don't know.
Or like, oh, things are out of scope.
Like if it's out of scope, then like, you know, you're basically just like telling me
not to look at something that's vulnerable or like, I think there's a lot of reductive
ways that you could take that same kind of stance.
Yeah.
And while I, while I see it, I think that it's a little more nuanced than that.
Like bug bounties programs are not just designed to pay a researcher.
They're designed to set a neutral environment in place so that researchers can communicate
things safely with the program and the program can communicate things safely with the researcher,
fix it, not worry about like the researcher leaking their payload or telling other people
about it and all this other kind of stuff.
And in return, the researcher gets paid for that, you know, for not telling other people
about it, for reporting it directly, for not exploiting it.
Right.
That's kind of where I was thinking, you know, with this is like the incentive, the keeping
your mouth shut piece is a little bit more of a, of a, of a addendum to the whole situation.
The, the, the motivating factor for a bug bounty program is these, you know, researchers have
done high quality security research and deserve to be rewarded for that and to be, to be compensated
for that.
And so, um, I think that's the primary, you know, services exchange, right?
Yeah.
I mean, yes, yes.
However, part of high quality security research, in my opinion, involves how the delivery is
handled and so you can't just do high quality research and then start making demands about
what you should be paid and how it should be handled and how fast it should be fixed and
all this kind of stuff.
That's a good point.
Like, again, you're participating in the bug bounty program.
If you want to send stuff to security at it, you want to strong arm the program, you can
by all means, go ahead and try that.
And they may or may not respond, but they also may or may not respond in a very nice way.
Sure.
I'm, I'm, uh, you know, to all you hackers out there, I'm trying, he's just doing good,
you know, like, like I, I've, I'm trying to give him peace of our mind here, but no,
these, these are very reasonable answers.
You're, you're, you're coming across with Joel.
So, um, I kind of put, put you on the spot this episode and I will continue to put you
on the spot, but.
That's fine.
Listen, these are a lot of things that I used to feel as a hacker myself.
I still understand where a lot of hackers are coming from with these things, but having worked
on the other side, it, the answers and the reasons behind stuff are so much more nuanced.
I think it's important that people understand it.
Yeah.
Me too.
Um, with that being said, let's talk about the hideous piece of bug bounties, which is
dupes and particularly internal dupes.
What the heck dude?
Like what?
So, okay, hold on.
I am going to rant a little bit about this.
Okay.
So if you've got an internal dupe and you have not, you know, resolved this thing, right.
And it's within a longer timeframe than one would expect, you know, a couple months for,
you know, maybe even a high or medium or like a couple of weeks for, for a crit.
But like, okay, that, that seems like something that you need to still pay the researcher for
because you're sitting on that bug.
And like, I have put in high quality, this, I'm sorry, you can tell this is a little bit,
a little bit fresh.
Okay.
Um, but you know, I put in this high quality research.
You've known about this issue for a while.
My time just went down the drain and is still violated.
And it's, you know, our, our sort of agreement that we have in place of, I provide you with high
quality security research and you pay me for that.
And when no other hacker had reported it, this is an internal dupe, either discovered from
code review or maybe like an internal pen test or something like that just feels like crap.
And how can we get accountability for that as, as a hacker?
How can we understand when truly this is an internal dupe or whether, you know, we're
getting screwed out of our bounty?
Yeah.
So there's a lot of nuance and angles to this.
I think what I'll start with is that I'll address that last part first, which is how
can I be sure that this really is an internal dupe?
Yeah.
Main thing I would say is where's the incentive for the program to lie to you in the long term?
Money.
But I'm, I'm, I'm, for those of you that are actually listening to the podcast, I'm
rubbing my fingers together.
I'm taking a sip of water.
Yes.
Now, yes.
Money.
However, reputation.
Right.
And I think reputation from the program perspective, whether or not programs actually view it this
way.
But the reality is that your reputation is significantly easier to damage than it is to
like spend money.
Right.
And so like, you're going to damage your reputation significantly more.
With the hackers?
Yeah.
By like, you know, either lie, like if you lie to a hacker and say, oh, this is an internal
dupe, but it's not.
Instead of just paying for something, the damage to your reputation, if that comes out or whatever,
is so much worse than whatever you paid for that bounty.
Yeah.
No one's ever going to touch that program with a 10 foot pole.
Exactly.
Right.
And so like the incentive for a program to lie like that is just like, you know, you
have to think about it.
Like, why would somebody do that?
And it's not that it doesn't happen, but I think that there's not a great incentive to
start with for like, why would that like, what is the reason for like some random employee
who's running this program to like come sign on and be like, I don't want to pay for this.
I'm going to tell them that it's not like it's their money anyway.
Right.
Like, it's not like it's the, the employee's money, like it's not coming out of their salary.
You know, I mean, we can get into that in the, it wasn't in the budget part, but there
would be no KPIs associated with how much money this bug bounty program is, is paying or isn't
paying with their, I prop budgets are very, very complicated.
Budgets are very complicated.
Yeah.
Budgets are very, very complicated things.
The way that budgets at companies, especially the larger the company, the more confusing
and weird it gets around who gets what money for what thing.
How does that process get approved?
How do you get more money?
How do you get more money next year?
Like there's a lot of different aspects to budgets and that kind of stuff.
And you have to remember that bug bounty at the end of the day, when they make a payment
that comes out of a budget that has been set aside probably at the beginning of the year
for bug bounty.
And that pool is all they have to work with.
And so if they run out of money, that's a problem.
And if they have too much money, that's also a problem.
So we're kind of jumping ahead a little bit.
We are jumping ahead.
But I wanted to try to corner you with that, but somehow you eased your way out of it.
That's okay.
Let's just take it back for a second.
So like the main thing is that I personally don't think that many programs really have
much to gain by lying to a hacker, especially like it's a bug bounty program.
Like what is the point if you're lying to the main like thing that matters to you, right?
Like you might as well just not have a program.
That's my personal take.
I don't know if that's how most programs are.
I sure hope that they don't lie to the hackers, but you never know.
Yeah.
Okay.
Separate from that is how do you not get your time wasted, right?
I think that is really, really difficult.
Wow.
I forgot I asked that question.
Yeah.
Joel's got like a, like, okay.
All right.
I see it.
You're on it today.
Yeah.
I think like, so this risk is always there, right?
Like if you take internal dupe, if you just take the word internal out of it and leave
dupe, like that's always been a risk, right?
The risk has always been there that a researcher could have reported it and you find it tomorrow
and you dupe and your time is wasted.
Maybe you spent two weeks and you reported it.
You said, I'll report it tomorrow and you get tubes.
Okay.
That risk is always there.
The fact that it's found by a, not a security researcher, but maybe a security engineer instead
is very little change in that situation.
Now, I think that a lot of programs could do a better job at documenting that and integrating
it into their program.
And what do I mean by that?
I mean, if you have a security vulnerability on a public facing endpoint, you could create
a ticket on your bug bounty program.
An internal, like, you know, close it as informative or whatever.
Like, I don't, there are ways to handle that, but, or import it.
And if you need to reference it from like a public report that later comes in, you have
an actual report ID that you can reference.
With a timestamp and that sort of thing.
Yeah.
The other thing I think that you can do that's probably honestly easier is just be transparent.
And this, I think, goes a long way in a lot of different areas, but I'll talk about it
right now, which is that you should be defaulting to transparency with the researcher.
Number one, oftentimes they're bound by an NDA.
Number two, they're bound by your program terms.
Number three, they're bound by a privacy policy on HackerOne.
Like, there are a lot of aspects where you can have some level of comfort with the researcher
and just be transparent with them about what's going on.
And that applies in a lot of different aspects.
For this aspect, that applies in that if there's an internal dupe, take a screenshot of the internal
ticket and send it to them.
You don't have to include all the information.
You can redact stuff, but just like show them that it's real.
Like, if that's what, like, show them that it's a thing and that they missed it by three
weeks or whatever.
And I also think to that point, right, that as you mentioned, like, what happens if it
opened for a year or whatever, right?
There should be, programs should be taking accountability for that.
Okay.
Like, I don't think it's acceptable if you have a high or a critical, especially, severity
vulnerability that is open for a long period of time.
That means your security team is not doing their job.
They should be getting this fixed.
This should be a priority for them.
It should be a priority for the engineers.
I understand that there's lots of work culture and all sorts of other things that can play
into that relationship between security and engineering.
It does not matter.
If you're going to have a bug bounty program, that means you have to take security seriously.
You have to fix your stuff in a reasonable period of time, or you have to explain that
to your researchers and say, sorry, I know this has been open for a year, but it's still
not fixed yet.
And then you have to be willing to own that and answer as to why not, right?
And I think that's just a reality that a lot of programs don't want to accept, is that sometimes
stuff that should be high priority isn't prioritized.
And that sucks.
Yeah.
So yeah, I agree with you.
And I'll also take a program advocate side here, which is that internal dupes are real.
They do happen.
However, programs can be a lot better about being transparent.
They can provide more information about the dupe itself, show that it's open, that it's
being worked on, whatever.
And if stuff is open for too long, you have to take security seriously and realize that
a real attacker would go and exploit that if you had that open for a year.
And there's no excuse for it to not be fixed.
Amen, brother.
I hope that...
The work of the Lord is being done here.
Dude, that was fire, dude.
Good shit.
Okay.
I was supposed to disagree with you and debate that at all.
But to be honest, it was pretty on fleek.
And I really appreciated the point about them taking responsibility for...
And I think that's a little bit what we want with the transparency, right?
Like if we can get a ticket showing, hey, you missed it by two days, then that's like,
well, drat.
You know, like I still hate that for me, but it's not the end of the world, right?
But if I see a ticket that says that this problem has been around for six months or something,
then I'm going to be a little bit salty, right?
And so when they say, hey, sorry, internal dupe, boop, then that makes me feel a little
bit like they're trying to hide something and that this bug's been around for a while
and this program is just a pile of...
Yeah.
Not goodness.
You just have to remember that like every company is different.
The amount of resources that they have both on the engineering side and the security side
are different per company.
And so there's this thing called SLAs.
I'm not going to explain it.
I feel like you can look up what an SLA is.
It's a service level agreement.
Okay.
It basically just means you have this much time to fix this thing or deal with this thing.
Right?
That's like time to first response, all that kind of stuff.
Right.
Those are SLAs.
Okay.
Every company has different SLAs for tickets and especially security tickets.
Some don't even have SLAs clearly defined for security tickets.
And so if something's been open for six months, that could be the normal for the company.
Okay.
And if that's the normal, there's really not much to do as a researcher about that.
No, it's not good.
But you can't be like, ah, fix this faster because do you own that company?
Are you a C level on there?
Yeah.
That's true.
You know, one, the security team only has so much leverage.
And two, like you're asking for large structural changes to how stuff gets done.
And yeah, it would be correct and better and awesome to see it get fixed faster.
But if that's not how they prioritize security and engineering, then that's not how they prioritize security and engineering.
That is what it is.
And I feel like some of this is also a little bit on the platforms because like you, whenever you, as a platform, when you bring somebody on for a bug bounty program, you have two customers.
You have the company and you have the hacker, right?
And if you're going to bring on a client, right, a customer, a company, and then they're going to provide really poor service to your other client, that's not good.
So I think there needs to be some auditing in place.
And I'm sure there is at some levels in some organizations.
But I think there really needs to be some sort of standard SLA assurance or something like that where HackerOne or BugCrowd or Integrity says, yes, bugs, even if they don't always hit it, they should be shooting for bugs to be fixed in a certain amount of time.
Right.
And you sort of see that on the program policies.
But those numbers are very, very, you know, I can't come up with the word.
And the Japanese word just keeps on coming into my head.
But they're very like not specific and not stuck to, you know.
And so I would like to see a little bit more adherence around that because that's very important to the hackers.
Yeah, I'd say like around that, it's very difficult because...
It fluctuates too.
Yeah.
I mean, the reality is that HackerOne is a vendor for a company, right?
From a company perspective, HackerOne is a vendor.
You're paying HackerOne for their product, HackerOne.com or, you know, whatever, generic.
Or BugCrowd or...
We're just going to use HackerOne in place here.
Yeah.
You're paying to use that platform.
And in return, you get access to the inbox and maybe you get access to triage services.
And the reality is that they...
You're not paying them for advice on how to run your security program.
Okay.
That's a problem though, I think, if that is the case.
Is that truly the case?
I mean, that's not what you're paying for.
You know, you're not paying them to tell you how to run your...
Like they can give you advice, but it would be unsolicited, right?
And so that is like...
Like I think it would be better if they were able to like meaningfully give advice to companies.
But I think it's not really their place to be doing that because that's not what they're being paid for.
And so not only is it an overstep of their services, but it's like not really their concern.
Like their concern is to provide an excellent BugBounty platform that helps the company communicate with researchers and receive vulnerabilities and all that kind of stuff.
Yeah, but you can't provide an excellent BugBounty platform without it being a two-way street, right?
So if you're not ensuring that the program is providing a quality experience to the hackers, then you can't...
Then the platform is going down, right?
But again, like what is HackerOne going to do?
Say like, oh, in order to sign this contract, you have to provide us that, you know, you're going to adjust your security SLAs and do all the...
Like these things would be blockers that...
That'd be great.
I mean, they would just lose business, right?
That's true.
And it's a company, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah, the company will be like, okay, we're just going to go to BugCrow who doesn't require that.
Or like whatever, right?
Like the reality is that I think that would be too much of a blocker when the goal is to just get companies to adopt security more by having a BugBounty program and having a way to receive vulnerability reports.
And to make it a requirement that they have to like vamp up and buff their whole security program in order to receive reports.
That's really difficult.
That's a really hard sell.
Yeah.
I don't know, man.
I would like to see that sell.
And maybe this is a...
Maybe something that HackerOne or BugCrowder and TGD could run with and say like, these are HackerOne vetted programs or something like that where...
You know, and they have some sort of extra symbol, you know, sort of like they have for some of the other things that I'm not even sure I can mention exist in HackerOne.
Yeah, I mean, I mentioned this.
I actually had a discussion with them, not related to work, from like a hacker side.
I was asked as a hacker to go speak with...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, Joel.
You're not a hacker today.
I'm sorry.
Continue, continue.
But like one of the things that I suggested was like, if you have some knowledge about the tech stack that's being used, why not provide security recommendations for that tech stack, right?
If you know about stuff or you know about trends, like that's an easy win for your customer to like give them extra value for the product.
And maybe you later turn that into an extra paid feature.
I don't know.
I don't care.
But like, I think that there are certainly things that they could do there.
That's not quite going as far as saying, here's what you should have for your SLAs and all that kind of stuff.
Because I think that is...
I mean...
That's a very intense decision as well.
I acknowledge.
And in order to hit those SLAs, you may even have to bring on additional developers, right?
Which is a, you know, six-figure a year at least decision, you know?
And so there is a lot of nuance to that.
And I guess I can argue for the ideal from the side as the hacker.
But I just feel like a bug bounty program is a more mature security decision, you know?
And a VDP, everyone should have a VDP.
You can be throwing VDPs out left and right.
But I think a bug bounty program is a little bit more of a mature security program decision.
And by that point, you should have a grip on this.
Yes, I totally agree.
I think HackerOne would enthusiastically disagree with me.
Just based on the fact that it's their whole business to create and start more programs.
That's why we can say whatever the heck we want on critical thinking.
That's good.
All right.
So, all right.
I have CVSS as the next topic.
Little bit of a loaded topic.
What do you think?
Skip it and move on to budget?
Or do we want to...
Would you like me to yell at you a little bit here?
I mean, sure.
Like, here's my take.
Maybe I'll give you my take first.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
That's true.
All right.
No, you're right.
You're right.
I've been asking the questions this whole time.
Give me your take.
I don't think CVSS is very useful.
That's it.
Okay.
Like, it is a factor that you can consider.
I don't think it should be the only factor you consider.
And I don't think it's a perfect system.
I don't think any system like this, whether you want to be VISS, whether you want to be CVSS, whether you want to be ABCD.
I don't think it's a flying...
You know.
I don't think...
Okay.
Fill in the blank, right?
Like, all of these systems are trying to solve a problem that is incredibly difficult to solve, which is that you're trying to take a case-by-case scenario that is truly impact-dependent and generify it into a set of factors that you can apply globally.
And that just doesn't really work.
Like, we've had some really interesting discussions, me and you, with programs about this.
And, like, from an optimization perspective, every program wants this because it makes payouts easier.
It makes payouts more consistent.
It makes processing bugs and handling...
Streamlines everything.
It streamlines everything.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's great.
However, you can't do that.
Like, you can't just say, like, oh, if it checks these boxes, then it is this bounty or it is this bad.
Because some cases, yes, you can do that.
Many cases, you cannot.
Okay.
So, lots to unpack there.
Lots of, you know, coming up with a problem and not coming up with a solution.
And I'm actually going to take a little bit of a controversial position here that I am slightly truly believing, which is that CVSS is, like...
Like, the programs that really stick to CVSS, they...
It works well.
You know?
Like, if you look at Shopify and you look at PayPal and some of the other ones that really stick to it like glue, I think that rarely are the...
And maybe it's just because those programs have really good bounties, which is also another thing, right?
Those programs pay very high bounties.
So, you know, you could get your bug rated at a medium 6.8 and still be walking out there with, you know, well into the four figures, you know, range.
But, yeah, I think there doesn't necessarily have to be a system that makes it all streamlined and stuff.
But having some sort of baseline for an attacker to know, and maybe this is just a piece in your policy where it's like, hey, we really prioritize user data.
And if you can get access to user data, we are very, very interested in that.
Or we don't really care as much about user data as we care about, like, you getting access to our source code.
And if you can get access to our source code, you know, very bad.
That sort of direction is really helpful for me in understanding the threat model of a company.
Yeah.
No, I think that's a great point.
Like, again, generally I err towards trying to pay...
Like, I think programs should be paying by impact.
Like, I think that impact is really what matters.
It's not about, like, I got an XSS.
That's great.
What can you do with it?
Like, can you steal my data?
Can you take over my account?
Can you only pop an alert?
Like, what is the actual impact of this?
Because if it's nothing, then why am I paying, you know, a flat bounty for this?
Or why am I paying what I paid for the last XSS that could do an account takeover on this XSS, which can do nothing?
Right?
Right.
And I think that type of information is really important.
And what you said about, like, if you really stick to CVSS, then it works well.
I think it works well in the sense that you have a consistent program.
Right?
So what that means is that, one, your process is streamlined.
And two, your process is consistent.
So an XSS is going to grade the same, is going to pay the same all the time.
And if that's how you want to handle your security program and you say, we've got this much money for bug bounty and we're just going to, you know, we're going to pay 5K for every XSS.
We're going to pay 2K for every subdomain takeover.
That's fine.
But you have to, like, budget and account for that and just be willing to, regardless of the impact, you have to be willing to press that button and pay the bounty at the amount.
Right?
Yeah.
And a lot of programs, I think, don't look at it that way, which is fair.
Like, I don't look at it that way.
Like, we don't use CVSS.
And I don't think CVSS is a great solution because of what I said.
Like, there's so much nuance in impact.
And so what you pointed out about, like, what does the program care about?
This is something that I see almost no programs do well.
And, like, this is something that I think should be addressed from a – probably from a platform perspective as well.
But there needs to be a better way for programs to explain to researchers what their security threat model looks like.
And what that means is, as a security team, when you report a bug to me, how do I think about it?
What are the things that I'm looking for?
How am I grading the impact?
Amen.
And so there's not a great way to communicate that from the program side to the researcher side.
And especially for programs that don't use CVSS, there's, like, basically zero guidance.
Right?
And so those are the programs where you submit something and you're like, this is a crit for sure.
And then they regrade it to a medium.
Be low.
And, like, you know, you're like, whoa, what just happened?
Right?
And oftentimes it may be one of, you know, the early reports to that program that you've, you know, you're still trying to feel it out.
And that takes literal, like, multiple reports to start to feel out manually what does the program care about?
How do they respond to this type of stuff?
Like, do they care about this?
Do they not care about this?
Like, understanding that stuff in a trial and error method really sucks from a researcher perspective.
And so I think programs could definitely do a better job in saying we care about user data.
Specifically, even maybe we care about these user data fields.
Now, that second question right there, you'll have programs who will immediately say no to that just because of legal and comms.
Like, they don't want to point out explicitly.
They don't want to put targets on specific stuff.
Yeah.
Right.
And so, like, I get that.
But, like, that's fine.
Like, you don't have to go that far.
Just say, like, we care about user data and we would care if you can do, you know, X, Y, and Z.
The other side that I see, by the way, is, like, way too extreme in terms of examples.
Well, where, like, I've seen a crypto program, for example, where they will say, we consider it a crit if.
And then they have four bullet points with very specific scenarios laid out of, like, detailed, like, oh, you can execute, like, X, Y, and Z through, like, a specific.
I'm like.
Right.
This function never returns a negative number, then we're screwed, you know?
Well, I'm just going to go test this one specific use case that I know your security team already knows is invulnerable.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, that's not helpful either.
So, I think, like, being more generic about, like, the things that you care about, not the specific scenarios that you care about would definitely help.
For sure.
And then somehow figuring out.
I don't have a great solution for this either, but somehow figuring out some way to explain, like, the way that your security team is thinking about bugs when they come in.
Whether that be.
Well, Dangel.
Is it on the main domain?
Does it have access to cookies?
Yeah.
Can it talk with the main domain?
Are there ever cookies scoped to this?
Like, some of these things you can figure out as a researcher.
Some of these things the program needs to provide.
Dude.
Like, that was great.
And I think we need to start a critical thinking bug bounty program consultancy based off of this conversation.
Because there's a lot of high quality stuff in there.
And I think a lot of lessons you've learned as being on the program side and on the hacker side in extreme ways on both, right?
Managing some of the biggest bug bounty programs and also, or contributing to some of the biggest bug bounty programs.
And also hacking on, you know, the live hacking events in the, you know, cream of the crop scene there.
So, that's really cool.
And I think CVSS definitely has its flaws.
But for me, that consistency that you mentioned, that's kind of what I want to see.
Because if I can see the consistency, if I know what the system is, then I can work within the system, right?
That's our whole thing as hackers.
Is working within the system and making our goals get accomplished, right?
And we talked about this a little bit with Inti.
But, like, the ethical boundaries of sort of gaming the vulnerability, you know, rating system.
But at the end of the day, it reflects, it truly, if the security team's priorities are truly aligned with their vulnerability rating system, then it should be a dub for all players.
Yeah, and, like, I'm definitely winging this take right here, which is that I think CVSS isn't the worst place to, like, start.
And what I mean by that is, like, calculate the CVSS.
And then if that doesn't line up with your security team's threat model, try to figure out why.
And those are probably your mitigating factors, right?
And what I mean by that is, like, okay, if something is a crit, but it's actually a medium because blank.
Like, well, that's why, right?
CVSS can't really account for that easily, right?
Yeah, maybe it's, like, attack complexity high or something.
But, like, it's, you know, it's not, right?
Like, again, like, if you have an XSS that can do nothing versus an XSS that can do an account takeover, those are two very, very different things.
And attack complexity or privileges required or whatever, like, those don't really account for what's probably causing that change in severity, right?
And so I think, again, being transparent with the researcher, describing what has changed that has caused it to not be a critical, but to be actually a medium or whatever, is really, really important for the program perspective.
And to help build those relationships that lead to fruitful security research from your hacker base, right?
Yeah.
Good stuff, man.
Whew.
We are an hour and one minute in.
I've had a little bit of a draining day.
So that steam, that steam that was, you know, coming out earlier.
I'm still going.
Just read them as you wrote them.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, okay.
I'll just read them as I wrote them.
Let me just hit you with this one, big boy.
Regarding bounty payments and budgets, it's not your money.
So why are you so freaking stingy with it?
Yeah.
Okay.
So as I mentioned, bounties are, sorry, budgets are very complex topics.
Let's see how generic I can talk about this.
Essentially, you have to imagine a budget for a company as a giant pool of money that starts from the very, very top of that company.
And every single layer of management you go down, you chop another piece off of it.
Okay.
And so.
So as soon as he said giant pool of money, I just like, the eyes went big.
Like, I'm like, yeah, that, that's what I want.
Yeah.
Right.
Justin wants the entire, he'll just take the entire budget.
I'll take that.
No, I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
And so the reality is that like money is complicated.
And when you make a payment, like I said, out of a bug bounty program that comes out of the bug bounty budget pool,
which is part of the greater security team budget, which is part of the probably engineering team budget,
which is part of the yearly budget for the entire company.
Right.
And when anything starts to shift, whether you go over or under that, then lots of other factors come involved.
It's like, oh, there's extra money here.
Let's take that and spend it on a security tool.
Or let's, oh, you don't, you didn't use all that money.
All right.
Well, that other team is going to get more money because they needed it last year.
And so there's like all sorts of like weird meta aspects to paying a bounty and to where that money is coming from.
That, yes, it's not your money, but it kind of is your money because it's your team's money.
It's, you know, it's the money that you have for next year or it's the tooling that you're planning to buy in six months.
Or like there are a lot of other aspects where it kind of is your money.
It's your money in the sense that you have like ownership over it, but it's not your money.
Right.
Yeah.
And so I think that's where.
You're a steward of that money.
You're supposed to be using this money for the greater purpose of the organization that you're working with.
Makes sense.
Yeah.
And I think very few companies are able to keep up with the type of pace that gets set by live hacking event programs specifically.
I think it really sets an unfair bar in terms of what people should be paying and what's considered a reasonable bounty.
Those are just blank checks sometimes too, you know, to the security team.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, it's like, you know, you see a program that pays multiple millions of dollars at a single event.
That is many times the full security budget for plenty of companies.
And like the reality is that not every company can do that.
Not every company can keep up with that.
And so that is also part of where the stinginess comes in, which is like, is this something that we actually care about?
Like if I'm looking at my budget and what I'm supposed to be paying for this, is this something that's worth paying?
You know, say I have $50,000 in my budget.
Is this worth paying 20% for a 10K crit?
Right.
Of my whole budget for who knows how, like, you know, what if it's February and you got 50K in your budget and you just got a 10K crit?
You got 50K in your budget.
I don't know.
And it's like, oh, okay, I'm two months in and I just blew 20% of my budget.
Like what do I, you know, what happens if this happens again in two weeks?
Right.
And so I think there's a lot of aspects where programs start to get stingy because there are other aspects involved around like where's the money going to come from?
And how's the company doing in general?
Yeah.
I mean, there's tons of other things.
But yeah, a lot of it is just really comes down to budgets are weird and confusing and getting more money or having extra money is like a weird balance.
And every company kind of handles that differently.
A lot of times it's not received well in either case.
But on the flip side of that, you know, the more bounties you pay, the more budget you may get allocated the next year.
Yeah, man.
I have a really...
I can really help you out here.
You know, like I could submit, you could pay them really good and then you'll get more money next year.
This is not going to be a popular take, but I think that programs that pay a lot of money are really just messing it all up.
What?
Like, here's the thing.
Here's the thing.
Okay.
As a bug bounty researcher, would I like to get lots of bounties?
Absolutely.
Every day of the week.
As a program, would I want to be paying millions of dollars every single year because my security team is not finding those things and not fixing those things and not securing from the inside, but putting all this emphasis in money.
Literally just like spending money because we're paying other researchers to find these things that our team should be proactively trying to fix and find.
I don't know, man.
I think...
And I know you said it's a hot take or whatever, and it is.
Oh, for sure.
It's a hot take.
But let's say this, okay?
Let's say you spend $500 or...
Not $500.
$500,000 on your security...
That's a big difference.
I know.
I'm sorry.
$500,000 on your bug bounty reports for this year, okay?
Let's say what?
Average bounty of 2K.
So you're resolving 250 vulnerabilities there, roughly, right?
If you were to hire an employee, let's say a Silicon Valley engineer, AppSec, you know, employee, right?
Let's say you can hire...
Let's be generous, and let's say we can hire two of them for $500,000, which I don't think you can.
What are the chances that they will produce 125 valid vulnerabilities each in one year?
On some of the hard...
You know, some very hard in scope.
I feel like that's pretty unlikely.
For the math here, by the way, 52 weeks, five days a week is 250 days a year.
So you're asking for a bug every other day.
Okay.
Well, no one's working 52 weeks a year, though, as a Silicon Valley engineer, you know, just to be clear.
Sure, sure.
But, you know, they're also not...
They might find two bugs in a day.
Maybe 50, but yeah.
Yeah, whatever.
Like, I think the reality is that the break-even is pretty close.
But if you...
Again, like, I defer back to the fact that if you have a program that is consistently paying insane amounts of bounties and that number's not going down,
that means either you're raising your bounties and finding less or you're not doing your job.
That's how I see it.
Like, you're just not...
Like, a security team should be paying less bounties, right?
Like, I don't understand how your engineering team could be outpacing security so badly that you're paying more money.
And also, I don't see how that's a good thing.
It's kind of based, though.
Not going to lie.
Like, you know, like, at the end of the day, you know, from a business perspective, unless you're, you know, growing extremely fast,
and the number of engineers that you're employing to write code that have mistakes in it is increasing very fast,
over time, security is a cost, you know?
And that cost ideally should be going down as you understand what mistakes your company is making over time.
Yeah.
Or it goes up because of the value.
I don't like it, but I kind of agree with you.
Yeah.
Like, I just don't think that, like, I see so many programs that are, like, boasting, like, oh, we paid so much money this year.
Yeah, man, that's awesome.
But, like, why?
Like, what is happening internally?
Like, what is your security team doing?
Because they should be helping, like, cut this back so much.
Let me devil's advocate that, though.
The devil's advocate of that is that you're resolving actual vulnerabilities.
And you're finding out these problems.
Every single problem that is being reported and paid for is a valid vulnerability.
And that's the beauty of bug bounty, right?
So if you're paying out more money, it doesn't – I guess you could try to trace it all the way back down to the cost.
But at the point you're paying it out, it's already a sunken cost.
You already have that vulnerability on your platform.
And at any given point, if you could pay the money to resolve the vulnerability, that's the choice you're making because of risk, right?
Right.
Yes, but if the engineer finds it – like, if your security team finds that and fixes it and then also simultaneously fixes 10 other bugs, not only have they saved you so much more money, but also that's what they're getting paid to do.
You know?
Like, on top of paying bounties, you're paying security engineers to run the security team, maintain the program, like, do day-to-day stuff, and also you're paying bounties, right?
Like, imagine if you could take the $7 million that you pay in your bounties and spend one and a half on salaries and then keep $6 million to do whatever you – like, I don't know.
Like, it's just a really hard concept for me to understand why when I see companies bragging about the fact that they're paying super large amount of bounties every year, I'm like, yeah, maybe for like a year or two, that's a good thing to see.
But after that, you should be paying nowhere even close to that because your security team should be learning from this.
They should be making changes.
They should be putting stuff in place that's going to – like, oh, this happened because X, Y, Z.
Let's figure out how to detect that so it doesn't happen again.
Yeah.
Like, this is what – from a security team perspective, this is what we do.
And when I see companies who are like, oh, we paid $5 million last year.
Oh, before that, we paid $2 million.
I'm like, what?
Yeah.
I see it.
I don't love it, but I see it.
And it sort of makes sense.
And I think that is one of the things that's tricky about BookMountie as well is you've got to study the bugs you're getting.
And you really, to be honest, you need at least, you know, maybe depending on the volume of your program.
But a lot of programs need a dedicated asset, a dedicated person to that because it is so much research.
And every single time, you know, you look at a bug bounty report, you're not seeing all of the layers of research that went into getting that bug bounty report out there.
So there's a lot of reverse engineering that needs to happen from the program side.
And I was privy to a conversation lately.
Thankfully, somebody came up to me and told me about how one of my reports was dealt with within their internal organization where after I submitted this report, their internal red team is actually, you know, sort of weaponizing these reports.
And they were able to use them to accomplish, you know, a couple tasks, a couple objectives that they had for the red team goals.
And that was really that was really cool to hear.
And I think that's the correct approach, because that that you know that the internal red team, the internal security team is learning from those reports and will will make sure those sort of mistakes don't happen again.
Yeah, dude, absolutely.
Like when I see programs like not taking learnings away, which is usually pretty evident based on how they're paying stuff and how much they're paying.
It's really frustrating because I'm like, dude, like your company is like burning money, like literally just like spending money, like hand over fist to pay researchers, to pay the engineers, like all this stuff.
And you could say like this is an easy justification, like, oh, we could save a bunch of money if we hire five new people and have them specifically focus on stuff that's reported by the bug writing program to like put preventative measures in place.
Like easy, right?
You could probably save the bounties that you're paying, you know, that you're paying, you know, just by doing that.
Yeah.
So that's my take on bounties and budgets.
Next question.
Why on earth are you not paying me a bounty at Triage?
I don't know, man.
Honestly, fun fact.
Did you know this?
I didn't know this.
HackerOne triage is supposed to retest bugs before their result.
Really?
Huh.
Says that in the HackerOne docs.
Yeah, go ahead.
Google HackerOne retesting first result.
It says right here.
Note for response programs using HackerOne's triage services, the triage team will retest the vulnerabilities to verify the fixes instead of hackers.
Interesting.
Huh.
I'm not going to lie.
From both a hacker and a program perspective, I have never seen that happen.
Wow.
I'm just going to put that out there.
That's pretty odd.
Have you ever?
Yeah.
I've not.
I've seen triagers escalate my bugs before, and that mostly occurs at triage time, but I haven't seen them retest it.
Okay.
But retesting, hold on.
We've got a section, Joel, for retesting.
So we'll come to the retesting thing.
Is that where we're at right now?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The question is, why are you not issuing a bounty at triage for-
Oh, at triage?
Yeah, at triage, not at retest.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I mean, yeah.
Okay.
I think that's a little bit more pointed.
I'm going to make it less pointed.
No, no, no.
I'm going to leave it.
I'm going to leave it pointed.
Why not pay at triage?
Sure.
I mean, I think you probably should pay minimum bounty at triage, at least.
The hard part about paying at triage is that oftentimes you don't know what the full impact
is until you can do some further investigation.
Sure.
That's where it gets hard to pay a full bounty at triage.
However, like I said, I think programs should probably be trying to pay minimum bounty at triage,
meaning you know that this is at the very minimum X severity, medium, high, whatever,
low.
Okay.
Pay that bounty.
You know you're going to pay at least that much.
Pay some money.
Show them that you appreciate the report, that it's being worked on.
Give them some crumbs.
Okay.
Yeah.
Figure out the impact.
We've all heard this argument, right?
But like why?
So I feel like there's two things here, right?
There's the internal technical assessment, right?
That will tell you exactly what the impact of that bug is, you know, assuming you do a
thorough investigation and don't miss anything, right?
But then there's also the triage assessment, which is just like, oh no, that's bad.
I don't want that happening to my organization, right?
So like, you know, you go to the report, you click on the link, the alert box pops up.
We can all acknowledge that normally that's bad, right?
Right.
You know?
Sure.
So I feel like at that point, you triage the bug, pay the lowest bounty.
And I mean, I just wonder, like, do you have any insight into why we don't see this more
often?
Because I feel like this is a pretty easy thing to do.
No.
I mean, honestly, this is one of those things that like seems like a no brainer to me.
Yeah.
I don't, I have yet to get a really good understanding why programs don't do that.
Okay.
I think it really just boils down to the nuance, which is that they don't want to overpay for
something accidentally, because if the minimum is so high that it's maybe higher than a maximum
for something else.
Sure.
They don't want to make that call.
And that's fair.
But I think like you should be doing your best to try and pay the minimum acceptable
bounty that you like know for sure this is going to be at least as much.
And, you know, I, I, yeah, I just think programs should be doing that.
Well, you know, that's not the answer I wanted to hear, Joel.
I wanted to hear.
I'm sorry.
Like, like, I mean, I cannot fathom why a program would, would be like, this is worth
at least as much, but we're going to wait.
All right.
Until it's fixed.
I mean, I don't know.
That makes sense.
Like you're going to pay them one way or another.
Frustrating.
I don't know.
It's frustrating.
All right.
So let's talk about the retesting.
So hacker one is supposed to do, apparently using hacker one retest services.
Hacker one is supposed to retest.
If you have H1 triage.
Yeah.
I mean, if you're managing.
According to the H1 triage services.
If you're using hacker one's triage services, the triage team is supposed to retest the
vulnerability to verify the fix as a set of hackers.
Now, again, I, in my experience in hacking, both as a researcher and as a program operator,
I've never seen H1 triage do that.
Not to the best of my knowledge.
Yeah.
I think they need to pull that out of those docs.
Everybody that I've talked to has been like, uh, really?
That is mega workload increase for them.
For sure.
Yes.
Yeah.
And like triage already has an enough thing, but yeah, I don't, I don't know.
Um, I think the whole, like, should we pay retesting the fact that it's a feature there
and it's like literally $50, just do it.
Yeah.
Just pay it.
Right.
Like, I think if you're getting a $5,000 bounty, me paying you $50 more shouldn't matter to
you as a researcher personally.
Like, I'm like, what is the, what is the, the, you know, whatever.
To be honest, the $50 isn't even really, to be honest, the $50 isn't really that motivating
in general, even like, I feel like if you want, especially when programs take so freaking
long to resolve the bug, like if you resolve the bug in 24 hours and you asked me to retest,
I'm going to retest for you.
Cause I appreciate you, you know, like, cause that's, cause that's good shit.
Right.
And, and I want to encourage that.
But if, if it's three months down the line, I got pinged the other day to do a retest of
a bug that I reported in January.
And I said, uh, actually I didn't say anything cause I was like, I'm not even going to respond
to that because there's no way that I'm about to come back to this report and, and reread
the whole report and go set up the whole thing that I need to do and refigure out, you know,
where that bug was and get back in that flow state to be able to actually test this without
any sort of incentivization.
That's why like random people get invited to perform retests when you don't accept it.
And that's bullshit by the way.
That is, that is absolutely not, not cool.
That definitely feels like a little bit of a weird thing in terms of like my bug being,
yeah.
And whatever.
But, but nonetheless, um, you know, I think paid retesting should be the normal.
I think even if you don't pay someone to retest, doing that retest form should be part of the
normal flow because from a program perspective, the hacker is prompted to say whether or not
it was fixed and whether or not they found any bypasses.
And that's really, I think why programs ask researchers to do retesting in the first place
is because they don't want to say, okay, this is fixed.
And then tomorrow get a new report with a bypass when the researcher, like, it's not, it's not
really good faith.
Right.
The reality is that like, you know, like if I ask you to fix something and you find a bypass,
this is, and this is, I think is like the program should probably be paying like a bonus.
If you find a bypass, something like that, right?
Like the security team should also be checking it on their app.
It shouldn't just be like, oh, the researcher is now going to be an engineer and verify this
on our behalf.
Like you should probably check it.
Then you should have the researcher check it.
And then if the researcher finds a bypass, they should get a bonus.
Yeah.
I agree.
I think bypasses don't necessarily need to have 100% of the bounty paid again, unless
it is, I guess, unless some time has passed and unless that component has changed or if
the hacker had to be in a different, you know, sort of flow state, you know, it's like the
way I view it from a security perspective is that it's the same problem.
It's just an incomplete fix.
And so asking to get paid.
But it's still a vol.
Before it's.
You can't say that you pay versus off of impact, Joel, and then say that it's the same vol and
it in, in, you know, pay for less.
I mean, it is the same vol.
It's again, it's like.
But it's still a vol and it's still vulnerable and it's still on your attack surface.
Sure.
It goes back to the same conversation that we had at the beginning of the episode, you
know, about zero days is like if the, if the vol is there and it's vulnerable and you're
not actively doing anything about it and I make you do something about it, then we've
completed that transaction that bug bounty is built upon.
No.
Sure.
Okay.
But here's the thing.
If it's the same problem, like this is an ongoing issue, right?
This is not like a new attack vector, right?
This is like this, your bug, your fix is incomplete.
Then that doesn't deserve a new bounty in my opinion, right?
Like if this is the same root cause and something was incorrectly, incorrectly fixed, we're
talking about bypasses versus new vulnerabilities, right?
It's not like, oh, there was six months and they regressed or they made like a code change
that reintroduced this vulnerability.
We're talking about the same vulnerability that was not properly fixed and you, the researcher
found a bypass.
I'm happy to give you a bonus for that.
I'm not going to pay you the same bounty.
I'm not going to pay you two X.
I guess, I guess it sort of comes down to what we define this sort of researcher program
relationship to be because in my eyes, as only a bug bounty hunter, right?
This is my perspective.
My job is to bring you valid volumes on your attack surface so that you can fix them and
make it, make it better, right?
And secure your, your thing, right?
I'm not in charge of telling you how to fix it.
I'm not in charge of telling you, you know, um, I'm not in charge of anything.
I just bring you the vault.
Right.
And if you introduce a fix that it's not a complete fix, then I do my job again and I
bring you the vault, you know?
And, and, and, and I, I see, I see like, if it's something like, let's say for example,
something like, uh, um, let's say an SSRF, right?
And, and, and they, the, the, the fix is like black blacklisting, you know, specific hosts
or whatever, and you bypass it by using like a octal encoded IP address or something like
that.
Right.
Um, that, that is a scenario where I have brought additional piece of knowledge to the, to,
to the table and to be just, just to be clear, I'm, I'm devil's advocating a bit here.
I don't mind the bonus.
Um, I think the bonuses is, is sort of, is sort of fine unless I put a substantial amount
of work into bypassing that.
Right.
And I think, I think the researcher has to be a little bit transparent about that, but we
need to be a little bit more clear.
I think about what the transaction is, um, in, in book bounty, because at the end of
the day, the, the vulnerability that you fixed as you perceived it was a vulnerability of
this SSRF can attack a specific host, you know, in the scenario.
And, and I just brought to you that exact same scenario again, after you had already taken
that pro that, that issue off your to-do list, you're no longer actively aware of this vulnerability.
And I just brought you the exact same thing again.
Um, yeah, so here's the thing.
I think a lot of teams will view this as the same problem.
And I think rightfully so, because it's going to be all the same attack vector.
It's going to be the same fixed location.
It's going to be everything.
It's just that the fix is different and it's not that it's a new vulnerability.
It's the same vulnerability in a different form.
Um, and in the same way that the same vulnerability on multiple hosts may or may not get paid as
multiple vulnerabilities to, you know, they might pay a bonus because it affects multiple
things, but they probably, depending on the program, probably won't be paying you that
bug times that many hosts.
Because it's going to be like a single fix or it's going to be like a one single, you know,
usually it's like, where's the fix?
And, and from a program perspective, like, let me, let me walk you through it.
You submit a bug to me.
We fix it.
We resolve it.
We pay it tomorrow.
You submit the same exact vulnerability to me, except with octal encoding.
That really rubs me the wrong way.
Okay.
Like from, from, from a program perspective, like that, that is enough to like really set
things off in terms of one, is this even something valid?
Like the program could close that as a, as a dupe of your other report and reopen.
Like, I think like, not if it's already resolved, not if the report is already resolved.
Right.
And so this is the thing is like, if, if the report gets resolved, right.
And I think, again, this is why a lot of programs will go back and say, Hey, can you
verify the fix?
And let us know if you find a bypass?
Because if I say, Hey, can you verify this?
And you say, yep, looks fixed to me.
And then tomorrow you report a bypass to the phone.
You were lying to me.
Like, well, okay.
No.
Okay.
Whoa.
You know?
Okay.
Well, we do have incentive to lie actually, because we get more money.
Yeah.
Like the incentive here is that like, Oh yeah, that's fixed.
Oh, here's a, here's a bypass to it.
Oh yeah, that's fixed.
Oh, here's another bypass.
Right.
And keep farming that.
And I, I totally see the aspect like, yeah, you got to make a living.
However, this is the same bug, right?
This is not like, Oh, this is a novel.
Like, you know, but here's the thing, Joel.
It's not the same freaking bug because it's, it's not on your, like, why do bugs happen?
This is why retesting exists.
This is, this is why bugs happen in the first place is some developer somewhere doesn't know
enough.
And, and, you know, not to say that they need to know everything, you know, it's okay.
Everyone makes mistakes.
It's fine.
But, but at the end of the day, they don't know enough about the technology they're using
to implement it properly.
Right.
That's the TLDR of the situation.
And, and that same situation happens again, when we, we have a sort of a retest to new
bugs sort of situation, which is we've identified a vulnerability.
They've fixed the vulnerability to the extent of their knowledge.
Right.
And then at the end, and at the end of the day, that is off the to-do list.
No one's thinking about it.
No one's thinking like, you know, this is a, is a valid, you know, thing that we, maybe
we need to go back and like, you know, workshop it.
No, no, no, none of that.
It's off the to-do list.
And then the attacker highlights that exact same sort of problem again, where it's like,
you clearly aren't understanding the technology you're working with here to the extent that
you need to, to protect your users.
Right.
And, and I don't know, it just feels like, you know what, I think we're going around
in circles here.
I understand where this is going to go.
Um, I actually have sort of talked to myself into a little bit of a different position than
I had at the beginning of this argument, I think, which is that if our job is not actually
to advise you on how to fix this vulnerability, and sometimes it is, and sometimes it isn't
right.
Then I think retests need to be new, new, either more strongly compensated than the 50 bucks.
That, that hacker one offers, or they need to be new bucks.
Yeah.
Like, again, I think that the program should be fairly compensating.
Right.
And if, if that means like, if you find a unique, like a novel bypass, like I should be at least
giving you that $50 for the retest.
Right.
Like, yeah.
The reality is that like, as I mentioned, this should not be like, you should not be the
security team, right?
The security team should be verifying this themselves.
In some cases, H1 triage should also be verifying this themselves.
Like there should be other layers of verification in place before this gets to the researcher.
Not only does it make the security team look bad if the researcher finds a bypass to their
fix, but it also means that you didn't do your job well.
And so like, I think if it gets that far, like there should be at least some sort of compensation
for the time and the effort, but I don't see it as a totally unique new vulnerability that
deserves a fresh new payout.
Here's an interesting thing is that as an, as a hacker, you can like, say with the SSRF
scenario, right?
Let's say I put in a new host, you know, you, you hit that host.
Okay.
That whole thing goes to the thing.
And I know in the beginning, you know what?
I bet this uses Octaline coding too.
And I bet because there's already a white list, they're just going to fix the white list.
Right.
Or whatever.
Or the, I'm sorry, the blacklist.
And then you withhold that information from the original report.
Right.
That, that's, that is, that is tricky.
That is dishonest and not something that I would do.
Right.
But I also feel like there's a flip side of this, which is that programs also have this
sort of trickiness when it comes to impact assessment, because you can look at your organization
and say, okay, wow, this guy found an XSS on this one host that actually affects 1500 hosts.
Right.
And then pay them out for the specific, you know, the, the one bug.
Because they didn't know.
Right.
So there, there, there are things that eat, that both parties can bring to the table that,
that will portray honesty, that will maintain their, you know, ethical integrity in this,
in this exchange.
And, and I think that's a valuable part of building that programmer researcher relationship.
I think there's also the case with retesting where in a retest, I will do a retest if I'm
interested in building a good relationship with the program.
And they've sort of, you know, paid that same respect forward.
Right.
And so I think, I think it can be a tool just like anything else to build, build the relationships
that bug bounty is really built upon.
Yeah.
And I think like that point you made is like, I think it's a kind of a good way to think
about it.
It's like, okay, if, if I have two different ways to exploit this octal and normal encoding,
for example, if I submit them both at the same time, almost certainly one would be duped
on the other one.
Absolutely.
If I report one, wait for it to be fixed and report the other one, probably the same
thing should happen to some extent.
Now, if I report them both in the same report, does that mean I should get extra money?
Hmm.
Maybe, maybe not.
I think when it comes specifically down to bypassing a fix, that's when extra money should
start to come into play where it's, we, we fixed this.
No, you didn't.
Right.
Like if I was a different researcher, this would be a new report.
And that I think is where it gets to be fair, where you can start to throw extra money in
there, but simply as like, if you know that like these two things are both possible and
then only one of them gets fixed, I think you are somewhat obligated to tell them like,
all right, by the way, you know, and I think the program in good faith should pay for that
to some extent.
Yeah.
It's an interesting conversation, man.
I think, uh, unexpectedly that actually got a little, little bit, you know, like that actually
got a little bit tricky, uh, a little bit heated there.
And, um, yeah, I think, I think, uh, I think there's definitely a lot of ethics that comes
into Buck Bounty that's under talked about.
We should do an episode on that.
And I think, uh, I think I want to say it was Jew Bob's or, um, yeah, I think it was Jew
Bob's that commented on the Twitter post where we're talking about topics that that would
be a good topic.
I totally agree.
We'll have to, we'll have to think about that.
Yeah.
Um, okay.
So we are, we are at like what an hour 30.
You doing okay?
You got a couple more minutes?
Yeah, I'm fine.
Yeah.
Um, let me see which one of these are going to hit the hardest.
Cause we're not going to hit all of these.
Um, I guess we sort of talked about the sort of systemic issue piece when we, when we talked
about, you know, in this last conversation as well, um, from a program perspective, from
your experiences, do you think it's, it is dishonest?
Um, I guess we're not going to hit all of these.
Depends on the severity.
Um, if it's a crit.
Yeah, probably unethical.
Um, like I, I think it depends on two, two things.
Well, I mean, one thing really like severity, which should be based on impact.
Like the reality is that the reason that a bugbending program exists and the reason that
you participate in a bugbending program is to try and increase the security of that company
in a ethical and profitable way for the researcher and for the company, right?
They're saving money.
Yeah.
They're, you know, whatever.
If you start to hold stuff, the, I mean, there's a lot of tangential stuff you can get
into, right?
Like, why are you holding it?
Is it for a live hacking event?
Is it because whatever, right?
Like don't at me, bro.
What are you doing?
Like it depends.
I know a lot of researchers, myself included, will hold bugs like, uh, you know, for like
a week or two, you know, depending.
Right.
I think that's fine.
The programs know this, just to be clear.
You know, we're not, they know this.
Yeah.
Like, you know, the thing is that like researchers start hacking before the submission window
gets open and they might have stuff stocked up that they're ready to submit because
they want to submit it through the special event program or whatever, like, or they want
to use it for like a later bug chain or something.
Yeah.
I think the ethics of that are really complicated.
From a program perspective, I obviously we want to hear about everything, but the reality
is that not everything needs to be heard and reported.
Like if it's an open redirect, that is something that's a lot easier to make that decision for.
You know what I mean?
Like if it's something that's like, uh, mostly a non-issue unless it's used in another circumstance
and chained together with something, then I think that's, that's fine.
Like I understand that like, you know, that may not be the best case.
However, I think it's still something that the company should eventually hear about.
Um, like if it's like an IDOR that, or like an endpoint that leaks a lot of IDs that you
can then use for an IDOR, the company should probably hear about that to some, like in one
way or another.
That's, that's interesting.
Either through your report or either, uh, through, if you chain it, like, you know, put
them both in your report and then reference that report in future reports.
Like if you have another IDOR that uses that same type of ID, be like, as I showed in report
number.
That's a mature way of approaching it.
Like, I think that there are ways that you can disclose stuff without losing your bug.
You know what I mean?
Like you can prove that these things exist and these things are possible.
And that makes it a lot easier to make an impact case for your bug.
Yeah.
The same way that like, if you have one bug that shows that cookies are scoped to every
sub domain on, uh, on, on a root domain, right?
Right.
And then later you find another XSS on a sub domain of the root domain.
You can use that as a case.
You, I mean, you should use that and say, as you know, look, this happens.
There are cookies like sensitive cookies that have been previously scoped to main domains.
And, you know, it's a plausible scenario that it could happen.
Yeah.
I feel like that kind of goes against the POC or GTFO piece of bug bounty though.
You know, like, I mean, I guess you can say that from one, you know, from one or, you
know, X many programs.
I mean, like, don't get upset if the, if the program says, okay, yes, but it's not exploitable
right now.
That's a good point is like, you know, if, if you, if you do report it and they close
it as an informative, you know, or whatever.
I don't think they should close it as informative.
I think that they should, that should be a mitigating factor, but I think it should absolutely
be something that's relevant to like, okay, yeah, this was like six months ago, this would
have been exploitable.
Right.
Yeah.
It's a separate bug than whatever.
Like, I, I think that's, that's reasonable.
Like when we look at impact internally, a lot of times we'll ask, was this ever possible?
Like, was, was there ever a case where cookies could be scoped to the subdomain accidentally
or globally?
And then you could get an ATO with an XSS.
Like, you know, if that's something that's happened and it is possible within the bounds
of the infrastructure that's being used, then that's something that should be taken as a
serious consideration as a possibility of something that could happen or exist somewhere
else.
Right.
Like the fact that that pattern ever was there means that that pattern can be there
again.
Okay.
And so I think like, that's, that's something that should be kept in mind.
So again, like, don't get a mess.
Like don't, don't get all frustrated if the, if the program's like, okay, well, yes, but
this isn't actively exploitable right now.
So we're going to put a mitigating factor on that.
So, so what you're describing here is, I guess the most communicative or most respectful way
to interact with the program in that regard, which is like, let's say we've got the ID or
ID generator, right?
You report that to them.
And they don't accept that as a bug.
We're not upset about that, but they know that that exists.
Right.
And they're able to use that in their impact assessments.
And then the next time we find a bug where we actually utilize this, then we reference
it and say, here's the, you know, that's the, that's the report.
Yeah.
I mean, and again, like personally, like as a researcher, I probably wouldn't just report
that by itself unless it was a hundred percent.
If it's just IDs, like, like again, very low security impact here.
But if I had another ID or I might report those two things together.
And then again, if I find a third ID or later down the line, right.
Then I can say, Oh, okay.
You know, as I showed in this other report, it's possible to leak these IDs.
Like maybe I had them all stored as an attacker or I web archive them or whatever.
Like, I don't really think you have to get that in depth about like, yeah, like this,
this is how an attacker could have gotten it.
It's like, I showed that it was possible to get them.
Right.
Okay.
So yes, that, that makes sense.
I'm going to jump into the timeline section here.
Cause I've actually got a couple pointed questions that I'd like to ask and get your response
on.
Yeah.
The, the first one that I'm just going to drop is like, I'm curious what an actual root
cause analysis looks like from a program's perspective and an impact assessment.
Like, and why the heck does it take so damn long sometimes?
Like, like I know there's a lot of code, right.
But if you dropped me into a production code base with grep, you know, like, and, and I,
and I have a unique parameter name or whatever, I would expect to be able to find the code
that is responsible for this thing within an hour max.
Like, am I crazy?
Like, you know, that that's totally doable.
But what does that give you?
That gives me the piece of code.
Yeah.
I know where it happens.
But like, does that tell me what it can do?
Does that give me the impact of what, what is capable from there?
That's where it takes more nuanced understanding.
So finding where it actually exists, like where the actual root causes that is generally pretty
easily.
It depends on the part.
Yeah.
It generally depends on the org.
Like some orgs are a lot more organized than others.
I'd say that where I work, it's very straightforward.
It's pretty, you know, yeah.
Very easy to like see, oh, okay.
This endpoint points to this service, which is handled here, this line of code, right?
Like easy.
Other companies, probably not as easy.
It depends on the company.
It depends on how like well-structured they are.
But the hard part is like, okay, like what could you do with this?
And that's where it takes knowledge from like a security engineer or somebody to, or maybe
just even a normal engineer who understands what the rest of the infrastructure looks like.
What can that service talk to?
What access, what data access does it have?
So for each bug, are you having a meeting with these engineers?
Are you sending an email?
Is it a message?
I mean, what?
Yeah.
I mean, it's like a, usually it's a message.
So like typically here's what happens with the report.
And this is, again, generic.
This is not like specific to either program.
But like, I'd say like most of the time, report comes in, gets validated by either the team
or triage or some, it gets triaged somehow, right?
In one way or another.
Then that ticket, that report gets turned into an internal ticket, which gets assigned to
an engineer, sometimes with a root cause, sometimes with a fix, usually one or both.
And then from there, it's up to the engineer and their team to fix it.
And that priority is generally up to the engineering team, not up to the security team.
Sometimes it's up to the security team.
Sometimes there are agreements that say like, you know, security tickets have this SLA.
They need to be fixed in this amount of time.
You know, there's this much priority.
If it doesn't get prioritized, then we'll have discussions with leadership or whatever.
Right.
It's crazy to me that like you guys have such segments in these big organizations where
it's like, all right, like when I hear SLA, I think like external vendor agrees to do XYZ
by, you know, external time.
But you're literally talking to somebody in your own company and say, okay, we have an SLA
agreement where you got to fix this, you know, by this time.
Yeah, it's really, that's very odd.
And what you have to realize is that like the engineering team is not just like sitting
around waiting for the security team to be like, hey, we got something for you to fix.
Right.
Like every single day while the security team is handling other bugs and all that kind
of stuff, the engineering team is being told by the product team.
Oh, like here's a new feature we want you to write.
And can you implement this?
And can you fix this bug in like non-security bugs?
Security is not their thing.
Logical bug, right?
Like, can you add this feature?
Can you, whatever, like all these other things that relate to like their day-to-day engineering
job.
And then a new thing comes into that system and is like, hey, make room for me.
Yeah.
And it doesn't even, and I'm sure these devs are aligned with the vision, you know, sometimes
too of the product's iteration, you know, of the product's development.
And this can kind of seem, I bet 99% of the time, this feels like a blocker.
And this feels like just this annoying little task they got to get out of the way to move
on with their actual features that they're developing.
Yeah.
And so I think this is where like a lot of nuance falls in between like the relationship
between security teams and engineering teams and how to like promote security as like
a core value because it's, it can be very difficult to get engineers to give a shit about security
issues because it's exactly what you're describing, which is that like there's a new ticket that
just like popped up out of nowhere that is now increasing their workload and is now a thing
that they have to take care of.
Popped right onto my Kanban board or whatever.
Yeah.
It's like not, they weren't planning on this.
Right.
This wasn't something that was on their radar.
It wasn't in their sprint.
It wasn't in their planned amount of work.
And now they have this extra thing that they have to deal with.
And that goes all the way up the chain.
It goes to their manager.
It goes to the product team.
Like everybody now has to account for this extra load within the system.
And it really depends like on how the teams view security as like, it should be like a
helpful thing, right?
Like this is to like stop, like prevent issues.
Everybody should be owning security.
And so like, there's a lot of nuanced aspects to getting the engineering teams and not just
engineering, but all the teams to take security seriously and own it.
And that can be difficult.
And if you have a team who gives a shit about security and like they respect it and when
a security issue comes in, they take it seriously.
That's the best type of relationship.
That's typically where you see stuff get fixed very fast, like responsive, all that kind
of stuff.
But if it doesn't, you just have to realize that like you, you and your issue are battling,
are battling against so many other things.
You're battling against the product team who tells that engineering team what to do.
You're battling against the C levels and the management teams who are trying to drive the
business in a certain direction.
Like there are so many other things that the security team, as much as they'd like to have
number one priority and be the most important thing, just can't.
I wonder how we as bug bounty hunters or we even as external consultants to an organization
could help foster that sort of relationship with the devs.
Like, I guess I'm sure that's a challenge and one of the challenges that I've not been
exposed to as I'm not a CISO or even an AppSec engineer.
But that seems like a good investment of time.
It's like having your security champions or whatever and your various dev product teams
and stuff like that, that are really like you've invested in somehow making them appreciate
security and champion it within their little block, their little team.
Yeah, absolutely.
Like there are various ways you can do that.
I think one really great way for bug bounty especially is any valid bug bounty report is
an external vulnerability report, right?
Like somebody outside the company found it.
It's a valid vulnerability and it affects your company with no special permissions.
It affects it externally, right?
That's a huge thing that you can use to advocate and say like an external security researcher
found this volume on our site and is currently actively exposed externally.
We need to fix this.
That's a big deal.
That's fixing it, right?
Yeah.
That's a big deal.
And I think that you can at least use that to help drive the importance of it.
And then you can use that again as backup when you're like training your engineers.
So like one of the things that we'll do internally is we'll take a lot of these things that we
notice like systemic problems or like core problems that are popping up over and over
again.
And we'll try and turn that into trainings that then every single new hire engineer gets
put through this security training that walks them through like how the security process
should work.
Yeah.
But it's a training, you know, like.
No, no.
But this is like day one.
Okay.
Yeah.
But like.
Trust me.
It works.
I promise we wouldn't do it if it didn't work.
Okay.
It really, it helps a lot.
It helps people understand that like security matters and it's taken seriously.
It shows them from day one that security is not just like a background process, but it
is part of the process.
Yeah.
And that when they, when they want to like expose a new endpoint, security has to know
and security has to review that.
And like, that is like a real core part of the engineering process.
And it, it states it as a fact instead of an option.
That, that, that is important.
And I'm sure that that's an intentional cultural thing that you've got to foster.
And you know, my next question here on the list is like, why the frick does it take
so long?
Like, aren't you guys using agile?
Like, like, can't you just like slip it into the next sprint and it'd be fixed in the week?
You know, if it were up to me, absolutely.
Yes.
But again, that's a company culture problem.
Yep.
It's a company culture problem.
It's a, it's a, you're fighting with all these other teams and all these other organizations
and all these other tickets and all these other everything.
Like, again, if it was just security and three engineers, I'm sure the relationship
would be such that like, we'd be like, Hey, can you fix this?
And they'd be like, sure.
And then they'd fix it.
But there are so many other players that are invisible to the researcher and so many other,
like, you know, just communication and organizational type problems that are really hard to get around.
That even if the security team knows in their heart that this is an important thing,
it doesn't always get received that same way by the engineering team.
And so the best thing that you can do is work in the background to try and make security more valuable
and have more weight to it when they say, Hey, we have a vulnerability.
Like figure out how the engine, how to get the engineering team to understand that.
Oh, this is an external vulnerability.
When the security team comes to me with something that that's, I need to fix this.
This is important for the company.
It's important for our users.
It's important for our data, whatever.
Yeah.
I just, I have a hard time like, and maybe it doesn't come across to the devs this way,
but I have a hard time like reconciling that they have two tickets.
One is like change the CSS styling on this button.
And the other one is like present, prevent mass data leakage of all your users.
Right.
You know, and like somehow brain, bro.
Somehow I mean, do I, I mean, is it, is that, is that really how it is?
Sorry.
I just slapped my mic.
Listen, like, no, like as a security person, of course, like security is number one for me.
I like absolutely security should be number one.
It should be the number one priority.
It should take precedent over everything.
Well, it's not my decision.
We don't, we don't have to debate that.
That's fine.
Okay.
Um, couple, last couple of questions.
Um, do you ever reread dupe slash informative reports that have been set that way by hacker
one triagers?
Or is that just like a, is that like something that would ideally happen, but like just very
rarely happens when you actually, you know, do something with it.
So I try to, yes, I try to read through, like, I try to watch everything that they're
doing.
I'm not going to lie.
Um, I hope that this doesn't portray H1 triage in a negative or unfavorable light.
Uh, the reality is that they have a very difficult job and that very difficult job is trying
to manage and validate reports across thousands of companies, hundreds to thousands of companies.
I don't know how, how many programs each triager is responsible for, but I know that I see a
lot of the same names across a lot of, a lot of different programs.
Right.
So, so the reality is that they're dealing with a lot of different things and they're
trying to do that at scale.
Um, like many, many times a day.
And that is a difficult job to do.
It's a difficult job to do it well.
And it's a difficult job to do it to the standard that, and like somebody who works for that
company would be like, oh, that's how I would do it.
Right.
And everybody's standard is different.
This is why external triage services exist.
Like once not provided by the platform, but like a cohort of people who you pay.
Sure.
NCC group to do your triage for you.
And those, that type of stuff that that's because it's much more nuanced.
It's like, oh, I want you to like handle this in a certain way.
And I want you to like, do this, these specific things.
Like you're going to pay extra for that.
You're not going to.
Oh yeah.
When you, when you pay for H1 triage, you're not paying for three specific people to just
be like your triagers.
Maybe if you're paying them millions of dollars a year, you'll get that.
Most programs are not going to be getting right.
Right.
Like the reality is that like 99% of programs are not going to be getting that level of
triage experience.
Sure.
It's like, oh, this is my triage team who handles things in this specific way.
And I get to tell them what to do.
In your experience, do the same H1 triagers work with your program on a regular basis?
Or is that, you know?
It's like the same handful of them.
Sure.
I'd be lying if I said that there weren't specific instances where we've like had one
thing with like a specific triager and had something had to be reassigned.
But like often from what I can tell, it's who's online in this time zone and like who,
you know, who's online, who, who's triaging right now.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's the same people.
Sometimes it's not.
I think not every triager has access to every program.
So there is going to be some cohort that is responsible for your program, but it's going
to vary by time zone and like what time the report comes in and whatever.
So yeah, because of all that, because there is so much like they have to do so many things,
they like nobody's going to be perfect.
And so for my programs, I'm going to look and I'm going to see like, did they mess anything
up?
I'm not going to do that a hundred percent of the time because I want to trust them.
And yeah, like there's, that's just way too much overhead.
There's no point paying for triage.
Right.
Just got to do it yourself.
Um, but, but if you see something that looks, if you see something that looks weird, that's
getting closed by a triage or what do you say?
Okay.
Let me, let me, let me put this a little bit differently.
Um, in the experiences you've had dealing, you know, talking to other program managers
in your own programs and your friends that are managing programs, what do you think the
chances are that a, if a valid bug was closed by hacker one triage, what do you think the
chance is that the program will catch it?
I'm not going to put a number on it because I don't, I don't want to.
Um, yeah, but I'd say it's pretty good that it would get caught.
It, it really depends.
That was not the answer I was expecting to be honest when I wrote this question.
Like if something gets closed, like it really depends on the program and it's going to depend
on like who's managing it and how much attention they're paying to it and how much of a fuck
they give.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
The reality is that like, as I said, a lot of programs will be like, why are we paying
for H1 triage?
If we're going to look through this ourselves.
Right.
That's valid.
Like, why are you paying for H1 triage?
If you're going to go look through it yourself.
Right.
But I think it's also your responsibility as a program manager to, if you see something that
isn't in line with the standard spam reports you're getting.
Um, and anybody who manages a program kind of knows what I'm saying, which is basically
that like every program has a certain cohort of things that are very common.
Like clearly just something you're going to get spammed on all the time.
Sure.
Not something that we care about, or this is like not even a security issue or whatever.
Um, and the reality is that like, when you see stuff outside of that, it's very obvious.
Um, and so even if it is like, uh, like it's immediately marked as like informative or duplicate,
you're probably going to look at it because you'd be like, huh, that's something different.
Like, that's not just what I'm normally used to seeing.
Now I think if you get a lot of submissions that can be harder to identify.
And I think the more submissions that you get, the harder you start to lean on triage.
Public version program versus private program, that sort of thing.
Yeah.
Like the harder you're going to lean on triage to basically like be that helping hand to
filter stuff out.
Like the whole reason that triage exists is, oh, we don't have to look at a report in a
new state.
We look at a report in a triage state.
Like, I don't have to say, oh, this is valid.
This isn't valid.
Uh, this is valid because X, Y, like triage should be like, okay, you're getting a bug
because we reproduced it and it's valid and you can turn that into a ticket.
Yeah.
Right.
Um, yeah.
Well, that's, that's, uh, that's reassuring, you know, to hear the fact that, that there's
a decent chance that if something was slipping through the crack and, and like you said,
it depends on the program for sure.
But if you're submitting a valid bug to, to a program that is not like just getting slaughtered
with reports all the time, there's a pretty decent chance that it'll get caught even if
it gets miscategorized.
Yeah.
But this totally depends on like who's running it.
Like how, how much attention are they paying?
Yeah.
Um, internal activity on a report.
What does that mean?
What, what, what, why am I not seeing this?
Like, what, like, it's really funny to see this as a question because like, this is
totally normal stuff from like a program management.
Okay.
So basically when you leave a comment on a report, there's like, you leave a comment,
that's it.
You know, you just like type something up, you press post and it goes into your, your
bug report.
Well, you probably don't realize that there's like hidden internal communications that happen
also on your report that you don't see.
So like when a ticket, uh, for example, if you link it to an internal ticket, that is
internal activity.
We can type out comments that are only seen by the triage team and it has like a red background.
Like you don't, it's, you know, marked as like, this is a hidden.
Okay.
So is internal activity a good indicator that the report is actually being worked on?
Or is there like, this ticket hasn't been updated in 23 days sort of notifications that
go on there that would trigger that.
No, that definitely means that something's happening.
Like if there's internal communications, that means that the triage team and the internal
team are having discussions on your ticket privately.
Interesting.
And they want that to be tied to the ticket.
Why don't you just do it in front of me so I can see what's going on?
Because oftentimes it's not relevant for the researcher to know these things or it'll be
like, for example, triage will say, oh, we're having trouble validating this internal
team.
Can you help?
Sure.
And the internal team will be like, oh, you know, you know, X, Y, and Z, like we'll give
you.
No.
Like, yeah.
Do your job.
Yeah.
But like basically, that's what it is.
It's like you and the, it's the internal team, teams, whether that's, you know, the people
running the program or the triage team or whatever, having communications, talking, trying to
figure out, you know, if something is stuck, that usually means that there's like something
weird going on.
Gotcha.
But internal activity is real.
Okay.
Yeah.
Good to know.
There are real conversations.
That is, that is.
And I'm sure, you know, there are caveats to that.
Like I'm sure some programs have like internal automation or whatever that will comment on
the ticket, you know, and say like, this ticket hasn't been bloody, blah, and bloody blob or
whatever.
But most of the time that's going to be actual activity.
Yeah.
It's a good sign that like people are alive and doing this.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's good.
No need to ask for a follow-up then if I see internal activity, you know, happening.
Yeah.
All right.
So two, two, two questions.
One, you can, one, you can opt to opt out of the other one.
You cannot opt out.
I already know which one I'm opting out of.
Are you, are you opting out of it?
How much does it cost to run a bug bounty program, Joel?
Like, come on, you got to tell me something about that.
I definitely can't tell you hard numbers on anything.
However, what I can tell you is that there are different payment models depending on each
company.
I definitely, almost definitely cannot tell you like what the per program, I'll tell you
off air.
How about that?
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I'll tell you off air.
It is definitely tens of thousands of dollars a year.
Okay.
Minimum.
And that's, and then you also have like bounty budget on top of that.
Right?
So there's a fee for the program itself.
There's a fee for triage services.
There's a, if you decide to do that, there's a fee for the, that's like dollar for dollar
or more for when you pay bounties.
Right?
So if I pay a $5,000 bounty to you, that comes out of my bounty pool, which is separate
from the amount of money that I'm paying hacker one or whoever.
That makes sense.
Just to run my program.
Right?
So I pay a yearly contract to platform for whatever, maybe triage the program itself,
et cetera.
And then in addition to that, there's a separate amount of money that all the bounties come
out of.
And if that amount runs low, then you make another deposit.
Sure.
Okay.
Gotcha.
So there's, and then whenever you pay a bounty, you can potentially, you know, platform also
take some of the top off that or, you know, some amount of that also gets paid to the platform
in some areas.
Yeah.
That's where it varies.
I believe the newer contracting models, they don't.
They don't do that.
They don't do fees like that anymore.
They used to do a flat 20% fee, which I think is public.
Yeah.
But since then, lots of stuff has changed.
It really depends on like, usually when you renew contract, you might negotiate that with
the platform.
Sure.
To determine like how you want to do your fee structure.
Should you pay fees ahead of time?
Like all that kind of stuff.
So yeah, that, that varies a lot.
Solid.
Um, last question.
This has been a absolute freaking marathon of an episode.
I have not even done that much talking and I am exhausted.
I can't imagine how you must feel, but talk to me about LHE's.
Are they live hacking events?
For those of you that aren't familiar with the acronym, how does that feel from the program
side?
Is that stressful?
Is that fun?
Is that all of the above?
Yeah.
All the above, all the above.
Um, I run a couple live hacking events.
Um, while I was at Uber, they are, they don't call it a war room for nothing.
Okay.
Like, uh, yeah, it's, um, it's, it's chaos in there.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay.
So basically here's the picture, right?
You've got at least a couple of people from the security team in there.
You've probably got at least a couple of people from the engineering team or people on call
remotely who can help answer questions and nap like direct tickets in the right direction.
And then you've got the triage team and the H1 team in there as well.
So triage is helping like validate stuff in real time, like log in test stuff.
Like if they need something from the security team for help retesting or whatever, they're
there.
Security team is there to like, look at all the bugs, address criticality, address impact,
address validity.
Um, see if this is stuff that needs to be fixed.
Like now, now, now, or can wait until after the event, um, figuring out payouts.
That's like a huge part of it is like the security team meeting, trying to decide impact
on like 10 bugs every hour or more.
Yeah.
It's like a weekly meeting that happens, but actually every hour.
It's like, you're sitting down and you're like, okay, what about this one?
Oh, what could they do?
Uh, they could do this, this, this.
Okay.
Uh, well that's, you know, this severity, blah, blah, blah.
Let's pay it out this next.
Yeah.
That's intense, man.
And you're making, you're making big money decisions on the fly like that.
That's nuts.
Yes.
Yeah.
So definitely, um, stressful, definitely a lot of fun.
I think like in hindsight, it's such a great experience to get to have that real, like
face-to-face interaction with the researcher and those relationships.
Um, there's so much like partnership building that you can do in just like that one day of
hacking between like top hackers and your program that like build like lifelong, like sorts of
relationships with those hackers now want to come hack on your program.
They have a face that they assign when they submit a report and they have like a real,
you know, there's a real tie there.
Super valuable.
It, it, it adds a lot.
Um, yes, they're stressful.
Yes.
They're expensive.
It's chaos.
But, uh, is it worth it?
Yeah.
I, I, I would certainly say so.
I think it depends on the company.
Not every company can run a live hacking event.
Um, there are certainly tons of companies who should not run a live hacking event.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
Yeah.
Like you don't have the scope for it.
You don't have the bounty for it.
Uh, you don't have the team for it.
You don't have like, yeah, like I think I was, I was telling this to the hacker team.
I feel like honestly, one of the requirements for running a live hacking event should be
that one of your people at least has to come on site and just sit in the war room and
watch what a live hacking event looks like.
Of somebody else's live hacking event.
And just be like, oh shit.
Okay.
This is what we got.
This is gonna rock my world.
Yeah.
Like I feel like they need some perspective because so many companies will come in and
be like, we want to run a live hacking event.
And I think, I mean, if I worked at a hacker one, my reaction would be what you do.
Yeah.
Really?
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Like, we'll take your money, but are you sure?
That's a pretty, yeah.
Like, like live hacking event training or something like that could be really a thing as well.
Because like, there's so much, like you want it to be a good experience for the researchers.
You want it to be a good experience for the company.
You want it to be a good experience.
Like overall, you want like good bounty payouts.
You want everybody to walk away happy, swag, like all these things.
There's so many moving parts, so many aspects that like, there's a reason why you see a
lot of the same companies running live hacking events over and over again, because they have
the money, they have the scope, they have the everything.
Yeah.
The stars really got online for it to happen.
Wow, dude.
All right, Joel.
That was a marathon of an episode.
I think this is the longest episode we've ever done.
Um, we definitely went down some rabbit holes.
We definitely, you know, went off on each other a little bit there.
Um, I, I, I think overall you, you did a great job answering all these questions and, uh, I'm
going to go take a nap now.
Uh, but for the, for those, for those few of you that are still with us at the end of this
episode, um, one, you rock to, um, uh, check out the new website, check out the newsletter
that's there.
Go ahead and subscribe to those.
And, uh, also we have a Kaido referral code, which we've mentioned on Twitter, but we haven't
really, you know, um, made mega public in an episode before.
Um, we'll probably announce it at the beginning of next week's episode as well.
Um, but for those of you that are still with us, uh, you can go ahead and use that and get,
uh, 10% off of your Kaido subscription, um, which we would appreciate.
And you would also appreciate because that saves you money.
Um, do you know what that code is off the top of your head or will it be?
Oh yes.
That's a good, that's a good point.
I should, I should actually say what it is.
It's the CTBB podcast.
It's our handle on Twitter, um, critical thinking bug bounty podcast.
Um, and that will, that will get you, um, 10% off on your Kaido subscription.
Awesome.
That's Kaido C-A-I-D-O.
Yes.
Every time we mentioned it on the pod, everyone's like, what's a Kaido?
C-A-I-D-O.
What's a Kaido, you know, like, no.
Um, so, all right, Joel, you got anything before I fall asleep and go take a nap from
exhaustion?
Cause that, that is a lot of talking.
I think that's it.
I'm glad I've been chugging caffeine this whole time.
You've been chugging, man.
Yeah.
You were, you're like, I, you know, towards the end, you can kind of see me like, you
know, lower the desk and then like start like slumping.
Like, but it doesn't help either.
Cause I had like a two hour meeting this morning and then, and then my, my buddy came over and
we just chatted for a little while.
So like two hours and you know, like I'm not really, I'm not an extrovert.
I'm an introvert.
So this sort of, you know, long form talking takes a toll on me, you know?
And so I'm at like minimum energy right now, but we made it, we made it through the episode.
So.
Yeah, dude.
Well, yeah.
Thanks for, um, thanks for having this discussion.
I hope that I helped to answer some of the mysteries behind bug bounty and reports and
what, what the hell's going on with my ticket and all that kind of stuff.
And, um, yeah, if we, uh, if there's more questions that come after this, we can certainly
do for sure.
All right.
GG, man.
That's fun.